Vessel of Hatred is the next big chapter in the story of Diablo 4.
When we last left off, we had defeated Lilith,
and Narell was sailing south with Mephisto's Soul Stone in hand.
This is a tremendous burden for someone as young and untrained as Narell.
But somehow, she has found the will to fight,
challenging the Primeval every step of the way.
In this expansion, we follow their path as Narell seeks salvation from Mephisto
and searches for a way to banish him back to the Abyss.
As we wrap up Diablo 4, there has been a huge battle in hell
between Anarius, the Cathedral of Lights, and Lilith and all of her demons.
Throughout this entire campaign in Diablo 4,
you're basically trying to defeat Lilith.
So you team up with people like Narell, who's this young, eager character.
And then you've got Laura, who is this sort of wise drunk.
He was the Herodram, so he brings this rounded, old-school thinking.
He ends up being the catalyst of the group.
Inarius believed that if he killed Lilith, he would be accepted again by Heaven.
So he went after Lilith.
He actually stabbed her, and Heaven did not take him back.
And he had this moment of, I've been wrong this entire time.
And she used that against him and ended up killing Inarius.
Her goal was to devour her father, Mephisto.
And we ended up actually stopping her.
And so even though she was defeated, she kind of gave us a warning of,
I was the only one that could actually save you from Mephisto.
Narell is left with the Soul Stone.
And she decides to take the essence of Mephisto and trap him into the Soul Stone.
Lorath is still with us and is going to try and help us find information on where Narell went.
And so we leave off with her sailing south with the stone, telling you,
do not follow.
The world might need you.
And over time, things start to unfold.
And you realize that Narell cannot do this alone.
And so you start your search for her.
When we pick up in Vessel of Hatred, the Cathedral of Light is kind of in disarray.
It became a bit fractured with the death of Narell.
So there was a bit of a split with the Cathedral of Light afterwards.
This created an opening for a whole new sect to rise up and take things into their own hands.
And so you end up with a militant wing of the church that is the Burnt Knights.
Burnt Knights are led by Yervar, a survivor of hell.
He's uncompromising.
He feels that he's final judgment and that he's going to make better decisions for the church.
They battled in hell, and now they're on this manhunt for Narell and for Lorath.
They want them to pay for their crimes, and they think that they should be the ones that have a say in what happens to Sanctuary.
Mephisto is the Lord of Hatred.
He's probably the one primeval that can create the most deep-rooted chaos, breaking up the people of Sanctuary.
In the events of Diablo II, he was destroyed. He's been slowly resurrecting himself in hell, and he wants to come back and bring himself back to Sanctuary.
And now that he is in this soul stone that Narell carries, this is his opportunity.
The Herald of Hatred is Mephisto's wolf form. It's this astral projected form that he gets to put out and connect with the player and whisper in people's ears.
The connection between Narell, the player, and Mephisto is the fate of the world.
Narell wants to get rid of him, but the more time she spends with the stone, the tighter the bond between her and the stone is.
The corrupting influence of Mephisto's soul stone is going to potentially convince her to bring Mephisto back instead of destroy him like she originally wanted.
So we need to actually make sure that she fulfills her original intent and doesn't fall to Mephisto's influence.
Narell plans to bring the soul stone into the Vault of Light so she can purify the soul stone of Mephisto's essence.
The Vault of Light is this really sacred place that Akarat created.
His presence is really important through the history of Sanctuary.
Akarat wandered the world speaking the teachings of the Zacarum faith.
His tomb is also said to be in the Vault of Light, which is in Nihantu.
Akarat is the one who discovered the spirit realm.
When the world stone was forged and Sanctuary came out of it, this veil was created, and that's what created the spirit realm.
Demons aren't there. Angels aren't there. It's a very special place for humanity.
And for a long time, the spirit realm was not touched.
And now, Mephisto's corruption is creeping its way.
I mean, that's a fear that everybody in Nihantu is thinking about.
Spirituality is really unique to humanity.
And in the jungle, it's a big part of their culture.
Eru is this elder, this magical being, a spirit born.
And he's really connected to Nihantu.
This is his home. This is his ancestral lineage.
And he's guiding the player on this journey to help Nihantu.
We actually find out that there have been sightings of Nihantu in Nihantu.
And we end up following her there.
In Vessel of Hatred, this is a story about isolation.
We start off with the concept that Nihantu is trying to do this alone.
But at some point, you realize that things are escalating.
And so we morph from this idea of isolation into the idea of being stronger together.
For someone that has been through the journey that our wanderer has, that Nihantu has been through,
you feel there's hope that Sanctuary is not going to be lost.
You get to see pockets of Sanctuary that we haven't been able to see before.
But it's still all in the same tone, in that same world that everybody loves so much.
Diablo 4 community.
Welcome to another Diablo 4 Developer Update.
This is a very special Diablo 4 Developer Update.
This is our pre-launch stream before Vessel of Hatred,
which is actually going to be shipping here next week, which is crazy to think about.
I'm joined here by Mr. Brent Gibson, Game Director for Diablo 4.
I know before we have our big show, you wanted to talk a little bit about Vessel of Hatred and what's to come.
Yeah, this is a really big week.
The fact that we're finally on the doorstep of shipping Vessel of Hatred is a bit surreal.
We've been working on it for a very long time.
You know, over the course of the last five seasons, so much has changed.
And we're excited to talk about some of those details today.
Everything kicks off with our epic journey through Nahantu, where we're going to be telling the next chapter of Mephisto.
And it doesn't really stop there.
We haven't talked about it much yet, but we've actually created a custom quest at the end of the story
that leads those players who haven't gotten to endgame, we'll get to endgame.
That's awesome.
Along the way, you're also going to find brand new ways to play with the Kuros Dunder City.
We've talked about this Time Attack dungeon that's super cool.
We'll go into more detail on that today.
We have our co-op PvE experience with the Dark Citadel.
For those hardcore players that like playing with friends, you're going to have something really cool there.
And we also have brand new ways of gaining power.
Whether you're hiring mercenaries and leveling them up,
or finding our new powerful runes that create runewords to sock it into your gear,
you're going to have a lot more ways to actually alter the builds that you've been playing with all this time.
So at the end of all this, we have the star of our show, our class that wants to go fast,
the Spirit Born, which everybody got a sneak peek at that quite a while ago.
And we have been polishing it and getting it ready to make sure that it's the most fun it can be at launch.
Yeah, and it's great because we're actually going to be going through all these aspects today in the live stream
with our subject matter experts across each of them.
So I know, as we mentioned, next week the Vessel of Hatred will actually be shipping and be released to everyone.
Right now the plan is for it to be out on October 8th, and that is still very much the plan.
Still the plan.
We actually did release a map earlier this week in our What You Need to Know blog.
That kind of pretty much contains exactly when each of the release dates are going to be.
But players can actually end up doing early download right now on PC Battle.net.
We do have early download coming up for console this weekend on the 5th.
So there's a lot of stuff coming down the pipe, a lot of excitement going on.
The other thing that we did talk about as well is Twitch Drops.
We do have a Twitch Drops campaign that is actually starting at the launch of Vessel of Hatred.
It's actually going to be starting on October 8th in Pacific time.
So it's about like 12, 16 hours, somewhere around there afterwards.
But there's some really cool back pieces, really cool weapons that you can earn.
And it goes throughout the whole entire month of October through like that first early part of November.
We also have a support of streamer program this time around, which is really cool
support of streamer actually really helps out some of the smaller streamers that are actually really wanting to, you know,
stream Diablo 4, which is really great.
If you give two subs for or if you actually purchase two subs across any streamer that is streaming across Diablo 4
and has this enabled, you'll end up receiving the mount that we actually just showed right there.
And if you do an additional two, you actually get the mount armor as well.
So it's a really cool way of helping out some of the smaller and mid-sized streamers out there that, you know,
really benefit from some of these programs.
And it's great to see all these new faces as they actually jump into Vessel of Hatred.
The next thing we do also want to talk about is a cool promotion that we're actually doing with Trolly here in the U.S.
Trolly actually makes some candy.
They're like Sour Bright crawlers and things like that.
There's actually some really cool weapon skins available if you actually purchase Trolly-specific products here in the U.S.
We actually have them here on set, but you can see all the cool weapon skins.
But if you actually purchase these and you'll see that they're clearly marked with like Diablo 4, they've got the Spirit Porn on them.
And you can actually end up taking a photo of your receipt, going to a specific site, and then you'll end up getting kind of the rewards in-game.
And you also have a chance of actually winning an Xbox too, which is really cool.
And this is a cool promotion that I think Xbox is actually doing across multitudes of titles, including like World of Warcraft, for instance,
because this was actually going on with the War Within here at Blizzard.
So, yeah, like if you're in the U.S., look for Trolly products.
Thankfully, we have a whole bunch of bags here.
So expect me to actually be eating these throughout the stream.
We've had like seven bags in the last two days.
Yeah, as we've been like prepping for the stream, like this has been my whole entire diet.
Actually, no, I've been eating normal food.
But at the same time, this is like my kryptonite right here.
So expect me to be eating these throughout the stream.
It's my favorite stream because we have snacks now.
So I'm like, this is perfect.
This is perfect.
But one thing, again, we wanted to mention, which is the release date.
I think we have a release date map here.
So, yeah, as you guys can see on October 7th in Irvine at 4 p.m. Pacific or Pacific time or California time, if you want to say it,
is when the actual expansion is going to be launching.
This is a global launch.
So everyone is coming out at the same time.
The world is round.
So you can't get everyone in on October 8th.
So that's why there's some in on October 7th.
But we wanted to make sure that we could get as many people in on October 8th.
And, of course, a little earlier on October 7th.
But everyone's coming out at the exact same time.
So looking forward to everyone jumping in.
We do have an action-packed show today.
A lot of stuff to cover.
We are going to be hitting up on the patch 2.0 PTR changes first.
It's first up in the agenda.
Because we have so many things to share, I will note, this is our 20th live stream for Diablo 4 that we've ever done, which is really cool.
And this is also our first time we're actually streaming on TikTok.
We already stream on X.
We stream on Twitch.
And we stream on YouTube.
So this is kind of a nice, momentous occasion.
But because of how much content we have and how many guests we have, we are going to say that we will have some small little breaks while we actually mic new people up, bring them into the studio, and then swap them out for other things.
But we are going to be talking first about patch 2.0 PTR and the feedback that we actually received from players.
And then separately, we're also going to be talking about season 6, season of Hatred Rising.
And separately, we will finish off the show with all the Vessel of Hatred features and going into a little bit more of a deeper dive, something that you were talking about, Brent.
Oh, yeah.
I can't wait.
I mean, we have so many people coming in that we're having to pack them in rows.
Yeah, exactly.
You're going to see multiple levels of people in the studio.
So we're going to take a quick break while we get the first group in for our patch 2.0 PTR feedback overview.
So we'll see you in a bit.
What do you think?
,ה slash finance, i'll see you in the chair.
Okay, good.
beating.
Alright, we'll break down the beam really great.
We are going to break down the beam like a 좋을 opposite pole.
It is it?
Yes, that's it.
It is gonna fall nữa.
You'll see it.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Can you hear me?
Yea, I'm just kidding.
Not much.
You have, say.
Yes.
Awesome.
I appreciate everyone bearing with us as we get people mic'd up.
We're going to be doing this a couple times throughout this stream, but we're here to
talk about the PTR learnings from Patch 2.0 PTR, which we had earlier this month.
Super beneficial.
PTRs have been great for us since we've started actually hosting them for Diablo 4.
And of course, this one was a very, very big one because we have a lot of big changes coming
with Vessel of Hatred in Season 6.
But I know we want to jump straight into it.
So Aislinn, I know you're going to start us off and talk about some progression changes.
Yes, I am.
So let's, yeah, like you said, Adam, let's jump right into that.
Oh, actually, before we do that, sorry, sorry, sorry.
I just realized no one knows who we are.
Oh, yeah.
There we go.
I was just like, wait a minute.
Of course, we have some familiar faces, but if you guys want to do quick intros.
Yeah.
Hi, I'm Colin.
I'm a lead designer.
Hey, I'm Aislinn.
I'm a systems designer.
Hi, I'm Charles.
I'm a class designer.
Hey, y'all.
I'm Anthony.
I'm an associate class designer.
Awesome.
Great.
There we go.
Now we got everyone settled.
Aislinn, do you want to talk about some of the progression changes?
Yes, absolutely.
So, Adam, like you said, the PTR has been just fantastic for us.
It's given us so much data and the feedback you guys give is just pivotal to us launching
in the state we want to see the game in.
And, you know, everyone wants to see the game in.
And so, yeah, let's talk about it.
Let's talk about some changes we've made because of it.
So, first of all, monster intensity.
Something we saw in the early game was people weren't noticing the changes in monster intensity
because people were skipping through difficulties fairly quickly.
And so we've decided to move monster intensity from scaling over normal hard expert and penitent
to scaling over torment one through four because you're going to be progressing through torments
a little bit slower.
So you're going to be able to feel the intensity changes, I think, a little more potently.
Yeah, there's a bit more jumps, right?
Yeah, yeah, absolutely.
And again, the intensity system was essentially monsters just become a little bit more reliable
in their damage.
Right.
They start to predict your movement a little bit more on the projectiles.
It's not a massive change, but it should sort of make the monsters feel a little bit more
aggressive and dangerous.
Yeah, they just become a little more lethal, I think, ultimately, beyond, you know, numerical changes.
Second up I want to talk about is one that I'm really, really happy and excited about, actually,
is that elites, unique elites, and super elites are three different types of elites you can
actually fight, if you know that or not.
That's a thing.
And previously, they all did very different amounts of damage from one another.
Like, for example, a super elite might deal actually two times the amount of damage of
a normal elite.
And what that was causing was when an elite spawned an affix, like lightning enchanted or poison
or whatever, the super elites would do two times more damage with those affixes.
But you didn't really have any way to tell, right?
There was no way to tell if an affix was spawned by an elite or a super elite.
And so kind of seemingly randomly, an affix might deal two times more damage to you out
of nowhere.
And so what we've done is we've normalized the damage that all of these different elite
types actually deal.
So that when you do see the affixes that they're spewing out, you can expect the damage you're
going to receive.
Like, you know how much it's going to hit you for.
Way more consistent.
Way more predictable.
Which is really helpful for not getting randomly one shot.
Yeah.
Our favorite.
And then finally, on difficulty, we have some changes to standard difficulty tiers.
We know some of you guys are looking for a challenge.
So let's take a look at what a challenge looks like.
All right.
So we have a level one character here in Kyovishad going to the statue to change their difficulty.
So what are they going to change it to?
Well, before they could access normal hard and expert, but now they can access penitent
at level one.
That's what we only play.
Why would we play anything else?
Yes.
So you have to beat the base campaign on your account once, and then you can go into penitent.
And let's see how that turns out for this person.
Oh yeah.
I'm sure it's going great.
Just a helltide.
Just a few demons.
Oh.
A few too many demons.
Just a couple few too many demons.
Yeah.
Mythic uniques.
So you can do penitent at level one now.
It's pretty hard, guys.
So if you plan to go into level one, be prepared.
But seriously, we know people really wanted to be able to push their builds as far as they
could as early as they could.
Yeah.
And now you can.
So whenever you feel like you're ready for penitent during your leveling journey, hop in
there and see how you do.
Yeah.
I know that was one of the biggest points of feedback we got during this PTR, which
was like, hey, we would like to see if penitent wasn't gated way further down the line and
if it could be brought in.
So it's now available at level one.
And as we've shown in the footage, it can be difficult.
But I think what's nice is if someone creates alts and they end up finding a bunch of mythic
uniques and stuff, which you can use at earlier levels, you then can at least potentially start
off in penitent a little bit earlier and stay with a higher difficulty in that type of way,
which is nice.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
We really want to embrace the sort of choose your difficulty that we really liked with
the mine cages in season five, four and five.
And again, to your point, alts just are able to speed run their way to max level right
by playing at a really hard difficulty.
So it should feel a lot better.
And it feels great to just hop into penitent early, like when you're capable of doing it.
It does.
It's just awesome.
Yeah.
We don't necessarily expect everyone to play at penitent.
It's really hard to play at your own risk.
Yes.
Yeah.
Your character needs to be pretty good.
All right.
Let's talk about some itemization changes.
So we got a lot of feedback that once you got to max level and you were starting that
ancestral grind, you were stuck with these non-ancestral items for a pretty long time.
And we do like that, but we know that people want to see the journey for those non-ancestral
items to be a little punchier.
And so we've made some targeted changes here to ensure that non-ancestral legendaries have
more, well, punch to them.
So we've increased the amount of master working you can put on a non-ancestral legendary from
four to eight.
We are also allowing them to be tempered twice.
Previously, both of those values were exclusive to ancestral items, but now non-ancestrals
can go up to that.
Additionally, we saw that people were going to like the boss ladder or they were just
finding uniques out in the world.
And it didn't feel like they were dropping as ancestral as often as they should have.
Right, because they're so rare.
Right, they're so rare.
And you want finding a unique item to be an exciting moment.
And so we've tripled the chance for them to drop as ancestral.
And this should help a lot, especially during the boss ladder, when you're killing these
uber bosses and they're dropping lots of uniques.
A lot more of them are going to turn out to be ancestral.
Definitely.
And this should mean that once you're starting around level 60, you have a lot more progression
on your equipment that sort of bridges the gap to ancestral.
We also heard a lot of feedback that that second tempered affix really is what enables
your build to come online.
And that's what we're trying to do with the system of ancestral is that you can get your
build online.
Yeah.
But then there's still items that you can chase that just enhance that build.
Right.
And we saw that like not having that second tempered affix and not having those eight
masterwork ranks really sort of hindered your ability to get that build online to get into
the fun and start blasting.
Yeah.
No, that's a great point.
Because we don't want you to feel like you have to find ancestrals for your build to
function.
And, you know, this change is working towards making that true.
Definitely.
So you still have those items you can chase, but you can still get those endgame builds
online pretty quickly.
Yep.
For sure.
And finally on itemization, we are adding some scrolls of restoration to the season journey.
The scrolls of restoration are the scrolls of tempering that we talked about at Gamescom.
You can use them to reset the tempering chances on an item.
And we wanted to add these to the season journey.
So you could just have a couple of deterministic ways to acquire them and use them on your gear.
And this, of course, is not the only place you can earn these scroll of restoration.
No.
You know, you can earn them throughout the world.
There's a small drop chance.
And we'll be actually talking about another way of earning them later on as well.
Yeah.
Definitely.
So I think one thing that I'm excited about on the unique changes, if you equate greater
Apexes in Season 5 to Ancestral, you're actually going to have a higher chance to get an Ancestral
unique compared to getting a greater Apex on a unique than live, right?
Right.
So it means that uniques are really exciting.
You might actually get, like, the Staff of Endless Rage, for example.
Maybe you're not playing a Fireball Sorc, but now you're like, oh, well, I have an Ancestral
version of this unique.
That's huge.
That's pretty good.
Yeah.
So it really, like, kind of gets you to experiment a little bit more.
And we really like that aspect about those uniques sometimes being a lot more powerful.
Yeah.
No.
It's, it's, we want that moment when you see a unique on the ground to be really fun
and exciting.
And seeing it drop as an Ancestral with greater Apexes is about as exciting as it gets for
uniques.
That's pretty cool.
All right.
Let's talk about some player power changes based on PTR feedback.
So I want to start by framing our goals for Torment difficulties.
So Torment 1, we want all content to be available in the game.
You can fight Lilith.
You can fight the Boss Ladder.
You can go to the Dark Citadel, you know, et cetera.
All these activities are available.
Torment 4 is intended to be aspirational content.
And what that means is you've already unlocked everything in the game when you enter Torment
1.
But Torment 4 is, like, the essence of Diablo, like, build crafting, where you're just pushing
your character as far as you can go.
And Torment 4 exists for that purpose, for people who want to push their character as far
as they can go.
And with that said, and the reason why I'm saying this is because we were seeing that
people were getting to Torment 4 way faster and way easier than we were hoping for in the
PTR.
And, you know, which is just another great, like, it's great that we did the PTR because
we saw that.
And with that all said, we've made some changes to kind of keep Torment 4 this, you know,
really challenging and exciting thing to reach.
We've reverted the skill damage bonus from main stat back to what it was in Season 5.
So we had actually doubled it in the PTR, but we found that that was just giving players
too much power.
Too much.
So we sent it back.
And we also pulled back on Legendary Glyph power a bit.
Colin, do you want to talk about that?
Yeah.
So we reduced the scaling on the Glyphs quite a bit because we found that it was really
devaluing a lot of the aspect rolls or rolls on your gear.
Like when you're getting 2,000 additive damage from a Glyph, it's really hard to actually feel
anything on your gear through tempering or through those affix that are dropping.
So essentially what we've done is pair that back.
We've redistributed it.
We'll cover that a little bit on where we put some of that power.
But overall, we think this feels a lot better.
Glyphs aren't just carrying like 80% of your power on a build.
It just feels a lot better so that it doesn't feel as sort of mandatory that I have to get
all five Glyphs and level them up to actually be pushing difficulty.
It's a lot more about what are the aspects you have, what are the uniques you have,
what are the nodes you're actually getting on the Paragon board.
I think it feels a lot better.
Yeah.
And I think one of the important things to say about this is that it's really awesome
to get a tremendous amount of power from one source.
But because there are so many different sources of power in the game, if one source gives
too much power, it makes the other sources feel kind of unimportant.
Yeah.
And that's not fun.
So we want to make sure that every source of power in the game is contributing to your build
in very meaningful ways.
Yeah.
And so this change is helping other sources of power feel really punchy.
Definitely.
Yeah.
Awesome.
I know tons of changes here with player power, tons of changes with like progression,
including difficulty and itemization.
Do we have anything else on progression?
I think one thing I think that's really important to touch on is the torment goals here, right?
Yeah.
Because it's a definite fundamental shift from season five in that you think about world
tier three into world tier four and you're sort of racing to get to world tier four as
fast as possible because that's where all the best items can drop.
Yeah.
And we've sort of just changed that to torment one is where all the best items can drop.
It's where everything unlocks.
But essentially torment two, three, and four increase the odds of those things happening.
So it's just efficiency, right?
Yeah.
We don't necessarily want to say you must get to torment four to experience the game or
to get the best drops in the game.
Right.
Similar to world tier four in season five.
It's very different feeling.
So we're excited to see how that plays out.
And we want to sort of see what you all think as well.
Yeah.
And just to reiterate, you know, all of the content, all of the best gear can be found in
torment one.
So if that's where your build feels most comfortable farming, that's great.
You can still achieve all your goals.
You can really max out your character there.
It just, you get a reward for pushing this harder difficulty by more efficiency.
Yeah.
And that's like what affords torment four the means to, or like the space to be really hard.
Definitely.
It's because you don't have to get there.
And so it can be really, really challenging.
And, you know, some players really love that.
And that's awesome.
Definitely.
Awesome.
Well, I know the next topic we want to talk about is some of the big system changes that
are actually coming with Vessel of Hatred, but, and also changes that we're applying post-PTR
from things that we actually learned.
Colin, you want to walk us through and start us off with some of the Paragon stuff?
Yeah, absolutely.
So again, we got a ton of feedback from the PTR and we took a look at Paragon.
That was one of the bigger changes that we made where we capped the boards because we feel
like that gives us a lot more space to increase the power of each of these boards and make
the choice more about what is the board you're looking for.
So what we've done here is we've added a bunch of normal nodes.
So those are things like stats that empower those glyphs to upgrade that legendary glyph
radius.
We added them.
It was kind of sad, like there weren't actually a lot of nodes to flesh it out and sort of
build up that Paragon, that extra glyph range that you're going to get from upgrading
it to legendary.
So we've done that.
We added around eight to every board.
And then the starting board, I think we went to like 12 or something like that.
Just because, you know, the starting board should feel really good with that first glyph.
The next thing we've done is we've taken a look at a lot of the rare and magic nodes and
we've just made them generically more useful.
So you think about like two handed bludgeoning damage on the barbarian is like, okay, like
I guess I guess I can only benefit if I'm doing this one very specific thing.
And we've just opened that up to say damage, right?
That's going to scale everything across your character as opposed to like while you're doing
this sort of obscure thing.
So we think that feels a lot better.
We've also just sort of taken a look at what are the affixes we're giving?
Like fucking potion healing.
Like I know you're all going to be really sad.
That was my favorite stuff.
I know you're all super sad to see that we've taken potion healing out.
But we've just changed it to healing received.
We've also just taken a look at things like damage reduction from dots and made it damage reduction.
So it should be a lot more generically useful and those boards should feel a lot more punchy
and open-ended, which we really like.
And that's sort of doubling down on the spirit of what we've done with season four atomization,
right?
Just sort of taking back some of these conditional things that aren't necessarily adding a ton
of value to your build identity.
Just opening things up.
And then the next thing we've done is we talked about redistributing some of the power on those
glyphs.
And we've taken a look at all of our nodes, all of magic and rare nodes, and we've just
buffed all of them.
So we've doubled all the additive bonuses on rare and magic nodes.
We've increased the damage reduction values by about 1.5x.
So they should feel a lot more chunky.
And as you're journeying through Paragon, right, it should feel like you have more options
than to just bum rush every glyph socket and every legendary node.
There should be some pretty punchy damage sources that you can get, damage reduction sources
you can get.
We've also done things like all the resistance nodes you have on the Paragon board actually
give max resistance as well now.
So it's pretty powerful.
We've done a lot of changes there.
So this is one of the first steps we're taking to really improve the Paragon system with the
new sort of philosophy of we want you to pick what boards you want.
And we expect to be updating more in the future.
Oh, yeah, absolutely.
And I think that this harkens back to what we were just saying, which is that, you know,
it's really fun for all of your sources of power to be meaningful.
And so we're basically just taking, like, the tons and tons of power that was in glyphs
and kind of slightly redistributing it to Paragon.
So going through your Paragon board is just more interesting and fun.
Definitely.
Cool.
Next up, we got, I think, Infernal Hordes.
Yeah.
So if you remember, Infernal Hordes was under construction during the PTR as we were fitting
in, like, how does this kind of work with the greater equipment chest turning into ancestral
items.
And there are three things that we really wanted to tackle as a part of this release,
right?
Infernal Hordes is an eternal game mode.
So we wanted to take the learnings we got from Season 5 and apply it to this next update.
So one of the things we saw was that loot was just dominating the reward landscape here,
like getting 200 legendaries from one source of activity is cool for Season 5, and it's
the brand new activity for Season 5.
That's awesome.
But we wanted to just readjust it, refit it back in.
We still have the codex of power that lets you store all these legendary powers.
So we felt like we wanted to take more of a quality over quantity approach here.
And one of the things that was sort of frustrating about that quality miss was that you didn't
really have a way to reliably target those unique items that were coming out of Infernal
Hordes.
If you think about it, you had to open a chest and just hope that you were going to get
one of the unique items out of this chest.
And that sort of led to a frustrating and tedious reward flow where you're just constantly opening
up these 28th of chests over and over and over.
I know I've spent probably more time opening the material chest than actually...
I mean, I think that's everyone's favorite pastime, just running around the material chest.
Yeah, putting the cool down on the chest like, oh my god, just give me my fucking shit.
So it takes forever.
So we've taken a look at how we're going to actually deliver these keys.
We've taken them out of the crafting system, but they're not too rare.
They're just uncommonly found throughout the world.
We want this to be like an oh shit moment when the key drops, just because you're going to
get a ton of XP from killing the Hordes.
You're going to get a ton of materials and a ton of items as well.
So we think that will make the keys feel a lot more interesting and it's not going to
blow your inventory as much.
Yeah.
You really want to use them when you get them.
So the next part here is if we could go back to the slide.
Oh, if we could go to Infernal Hordes.
Infernal Hordes.
There we go.
The council boss, no matter what, as long as you kill that council, they're going to
drop dungeon boss loot, which is going to be legendaries, crafting materials, gold, etc.
on top of the Infernal Horde unique items.
And that's going to scale with torment.
So guaranteed, every single time you kill that council, you are going to get unique items
that are specific to Infernal Hordes.
That's great, because those Infernal Horde uniques are pretty sick.
Definitely.
So no more waiting at the chest to get that drop.
It's just going to happen.
And it feels a lot more like the boss ladder, where it's like, okay, I want to get Infernal
Horde unique items.
I'm going to be able to reliably get those and get a pull at the slot machine there.
And then the next thing here is we've updated the chest.
So the chests of greater equipment are going to drop the scrolls of restoration or re-tempering.
So you're going to be able to get them reliably from the Infernal Hordes, not just the Dark
Citadel.
And that should feel pretty meaty and good.
And then we've also guaranteed some amount of ancestral items from that greater equipment
chest.
And ancestral items are very much more coveted than just greater affix items.
So that should feel pretty meaty.
And then the chest of materials is now just going to convert all your aether into materials.
You don't have to constantly open the chest.
Turn it into a bunch of master working materials, gems.
It should feel a lot more snappy and less time looting, more time playing.
And the gold chest is the same.
Yeah, because it just gives you a bunch.
Next up, I know we have the reward stuff.
We kind of spoiled here.
I know.
What the hell?
Yeah.
So we can just skip this because everyone knows.
So rewards.
This is just a bunch of miscellaneous tuning and making the game feel better and more rewarding.
Yeah.
So we've significantly increased the ancestral drop rate from Nightmare Dungeons and Whispers.
Thank you to the person who ran a thousand Nightmare Dungeons.
Yeah.
That's right.
Oh my god.
Yeah.
Definitely fixed the problem there and that should feel a lot more rewarding.
We've also added just experience to the Nightmare Dungeon completion, which just feels better as you're grinding that paragon.
Also while you're leveling up, it's like a pretty good hit of XP.
And then we've also done miscellaneous buffs to just miscellaneous things.
So Hellborn will drop loot.
Butcher is going to drop a guaranteed axe, I believe, of Butcher's Axe.
The world boss, Treasure Goblins, those are all going to drop a lot better loot.
It's also going to scale with Torment, which should feel good.
Yeah, I mean, it makes sense for these, like, I guess the Hellborn's not exactly a random encounter.
It's the world boss, but like the Butcher and the Treasure Goblin, these big meaty encounters.
It makes sense for these to occur and you're like, give me good loot because this is uncommon.
This doesn't happen that frequently.
I want it to be amazing.
It's an exciting moment and the loot should reflect that.
Yeah.
I love that loot explosion.
The Treasure Goblin.
Nothing beats finding a Treasure Goblin at, like, level 5.
Yeah.
Just chasing it around using your, like, basic attack.
Yeah, and it guarantee drops a Legendary no matter what level you are.
So it should feel pretty good.
The next thing here is we really love how players or how you all have sort of embraced the Stronghold experience bonus.
We've actually just done that across the game.
So campaign feels really good in terms of experience granted.
Side quest should feel really good, especially in Nihantu.
But what we saw with the Stronghold experience in the PTR is that two levels felt a little bit aggressive and, like, sort of forced you to do Strongholds over and over and over.
We've just paired that back down to 1.25 levels, which is still really meaty.
Like, you're getting an entire level from doing these.
Oh, yeah.
It's really fulfilling what we had hoped Strongholds were going to provide, which is an alternative means to level.
If you want to ride around the open world and do a bunch of Strongholds, that's absolutely a viable way to level up now.
We think that, like, all the quest content in general just feels a lot better because they're a lot more generous there.
The other change I'll note here is that a bulk of that experience is going to be from killing the boss, and it's a first-time reward.
So that means you're not going to be able to sort of, you know, cheese running Strongholds over and over and over.
Thank you, Rax, for showing that with your friends from your chat that did that in 20 minutes.
We rolled the record.
It was a good video, in all fairness.
Cool.
And then the next one here is we heard a ton of feedback that rare and magic items just felt like they're adding a lot of noise to Torment.
We're dropping a lot more of them.
Now they just get auto-servaged in Torment.
Hooray.
Get them out of here.
Yeah, get them out.
And then the next one is just a nice quality of life.
The Paragon glyphs now drop from the pit.
So when you're doing a bunch of pit runs, you're also going to be getting glyphs.
It just means you don't really have to, like, go out and do other things if you have a bunch of keys for the pit.
Yeah.
I mean, that's really nice, too, because, you know, theoretically you could enter the pit and not actually have a glyph, but now you will.
So you can find one and level up if that's what happens.
Awesome.
And I know, last but not least, we have kind of itemization and crap.
This is some big stuff here that I know will excite players for sure.
Yeah.
So one of the things we've heard a ton from the player base and you all is that I wish I could make a Mythic Unique deterministically.
If I do everything in a season, if I kill Uber Lilith, if I do the season's journey, I want to be able to get a Mythic Unique.
And we saw this as an opportunity to essentially create an identity between the runecrafting of Mythic Uniques and the blacksmith.
We moved it from the alchemist to the blacksmith, the blacksmith version of crafting Mythic Uniques.
So now what you're going to be able to do is you're going to be able to take two Respondent Sparks to the blacksmith and get a random Mythic Unique.
That means no matter what, as long as you do everything in the season, you're going to get a Mythic Unique.
And if you take those Respondent Sparks and you decide, I really want a specific Mythic Unique, you'll be able to take a set of runes and actually pick which one.
And what that does is the runes are a lot more flexible.
They can be traded.
You can also get some incremental progress because they drop a lot more frequently than Mythic Unique or Sparks in general.
So what this means is you now have two really clear means to sort of target Mythic Uniques.
And you now have a guaranteed way to make a Mythic Unique at the end of a season, which we think will feel really good.
Something that's kind of cool about that is that it gives runes this intrinsic trade value, which I kind of love.
Like they have this big purpose towards crafting one of the best items in the game, which is really cool.
I finally can get my Starless Skies.
Cool.
And then the next one here is you're going to be getting a lot of salvage in Torment because everything is getting auto-salvaged.
So we figured, you know what, we should probably give you some purpose and value to that salvage.
And now you can take it to the blacksmith and forge random legendary equipment at the blacksmith.
Yeah, this is huge.
I love this change.
And it also has a chance to be unique or Mythic and sometimes ancestral.
So it's definitely a great place to dump all that excess salvage that you have.
And then the next one here is more just sort of a quality of life and nicety.
We added runes and we're putting way more sockets on gear.
We've just allowed you to add sockets to gear with just the general salvage material.
You don't need scattered prisms anymore.
Scattered prisms are required for ancestral items.
And that just essentially means, you know, ah, I'm missing a socket.
You can pretty easily add one.
And then the next one here is mostly quality of life for alt characters.
But the jeweler no longer has a level requirement to engage with the jeweler.
Previously on the PTR you had to like trade gear to your main character, add a socket.
It was super tedious.
And we just made it not like that.
Awesome.
So tons of big changes coming across a multitude of systems within D4.
Thanks to a lot of great feedback that we got from all the players within the community, content creators, etc.
So thank you guys so much for that.
Thank you, Colin, for walking us through that.
Next up we want to talk about some of the class changes and everything.
And so Charles here is going to walk us through it.
Yeah, I'd love to talk about some of the class changes that we saw in the PTR.
Once again, I wanted to thank all of the players who, you know, gave a lot of detail, detailed feedback,
a lot of data on, you know, how classes were performing, all the different builds,
and the new items, new effects, and all that kind of stuff, new skills.
It's been really helpful in helping to make sure that we make all our class designs as fun and engaging as possible.
I do want to say that, you know, this patch is huge.
There's lots of changes, you know, as I said, a lot of new class stuff,
but a lot of new system stuff across the whole game.
And so we do expect some level of, like, volatility here.
And, you know, when a lot of things change, there's a lot of unknowns.
And so that's just the mindset we're approaching this patch with.
And what we're going to talk about here is not a complete detailed list of everything that we've changed from the PTR to live.
It's just kind of some samples and kind of talking through our learnings and what we saw on the class design team
and what we're thinking about.
And so make sure you check out the full patch notes once we're done with the stream.
And also, if you, a lot of the changes came in the PTR initially,
so definitely check out those if you're unfamiliar because there's tons of class changes there as well.
Oh, yeah.
Okay. So starting with the Barbarian, we generally saw that Barbarian class was a little bit too weak on the PTR.
And I think even on Season 5, I think it's just generally considered a little too weak.
Historically, though, it's been one of our stronger classes.
But, you know, in recent seasons, it's fallen a little bit on harder times.
So a lot of our focus here is buffs to some underutilized skills and legendaries and uniques.
So we've got updates to Upheaval to make it just a little bit more punchy, hits a little bit harder.
We've got updates to some of the uniques that talk to other core skills like Hammer of the Ancients and Double Swing to give them a little bit more damage boost as well.
And finally, there's a buff to the Martial Vigor passive.
That is a passive in the skill tree that gives you some damage reduction from elite enemies, including bosses.
And it might seem pretty small on paper.
It's just 4% to 6%.
But for every skill rank you have in that, you get that much more.
And really, when you're fighting the late game tormented bosses and high torment tiers,
it's going to be a pretty noticeable amount of survivability against those boss fights for Barbarians.
Yeah, those passive skills add up really quickly when you start getting a bunch of ranks in them and stuff.
So, for sure.
Absolutely.
Moving on to the Druid.
We also think the Druid was a little bit on the weaker end of the classes.
I think there was a few bugs on the PTR that we're addressing as we go live
where some of their effects, specifically in the Paragon and some of the key passives,
weren't quite working exactly how we intended.
So they might have been a little bit weaker due to that on the PTR specifically.
So we're definitely addressing those.
I also wanted to talk about Nature's Fury.
This is a key passive that whenever you cast an Earth or Storm skill,
there's a chance to cast the same skill of, or a chance to cast a skill of the opposite type.
And this was causing some unintended interactions with one of the unique items,
the Earthbreaker ring,
that ended up proccing or triggering Nature's Fury way more often than we intended.
That's because we have this concept of casts
where you actually need to press the button and then,
hey, you did one cast.
And whenever we do something like auto casts, which is like,
hey, I triggered a free skill with Nature's Fury,
that shouldn't kind of recursively trigger or trigger the other effects that are looking for casts.
But in that particular interaction it was.
And so we have fixed that interaction,
but then thrown some pretty big buffs to those items and the things affected in that build.
We still expect those kind of things, especially landslide builds that use this a lot,
to still be very powerful builds going forward.
But we just didn't want that one particular unintended interaction to be happening.
And that kind of overshines, you know, all the builds, right?
Yeah.
When you have like one build that's, you know, crazy over, you know, the top, so.
Exactly, yeah.
Especially whenever there's one build that's so dominant,
it really makes it feel like,
hey, I'm playing the class wrong if I'm not doing this.
And that's not something that we want.
We want you to be able to play all the different ways of playing the classes,
and feel like it's a valid and viable choice to compete or to complete the game.
Some of the other changes on Druid as well.
We've got some updates to Great Staff of the Crone.
This is one of my favorite items that lets your Claw and Stormstrike build
kind of synergize really nicely.
We've got just a lot more damage on Werewolf skills through the Lust for Carnage Paragon node.
Basically the same functionality, but just added 50% bonus damage there.
We saw Werewolf was particularly,
it was particularly falling behind.
And an update to the Untamed Legendary Paragon node.
This is the new one that talks to companion skills.
Previously it just gave skill ranks,
which kind of fell off as you got a lot of skill ranks.
Now it's just multiplicative damage,
and I'm really looking forward to seeing some companion Druids in the new season,
especially with the new key passive.
All right, moving on to the Necromancer.
So the Necromancer is a class that I think we saw a lot of variety for like Blood, Bone, and Shadow builds.
A lot of those were competing very well.
But a Necromancer is really all about minions, right?
And unfortunately we saw minion builds really falling behind from where we want.
And we know that minion builds are like the most appealing part of a Necromancer.
And so on the class design team, we're really committed to making sure that minion Necromancer is good,
and we're going to see some massive buffs to this patch,
and we're going to continue monitoring to make sure that the minion fantasy is really a powerful and compelling one.
We also saw that Necromancer was one of the squishier classes.
It had a little bit less defensive oomph than we really wanted.
And so we've made some updates here to Reap.
It's going to give a little bit longer damage reduction,
just makes that a little bit more usable for that function.
Same with Necrotic Fortitude, it gives a little bit more barrier.
This is kind of a passive barrier generation, so just a little bit more survivability in that late game.
And then the rest of it here is just talking about minion buffs, right?
We've got Kaylin's Edict, the key passive.
This is going to...previously it just gave you attack speed for your minions.
Now it's also going to give you bonus multiplicative damage for all your minions.
A bunch of the legendaries and uniques that talked to minions, like Ring of Mendel and Shademist,
that damage is now properly attributed to your minions rather than the Necromancer themselves.
Which means if you have bonus Golem damage, for instance, and your Golem triggers Ring of Mendel,
it's now going to benefit properly and it's going to be multiplied up by those multipliers.
So pretty big buffs for those legendaries and uniques.
Yeah, that's a lot of power for sure.
Oh, absolutely.
So moving on, we've got...next class we'll talk about the Rogue.
I think the Rogue in general was performing pretty well across the board in the PTR.
I think we got a lot of positive feedback, like, hey, yeah, Rogue feels great.
Like, just, you know...
Spin to win.
Yes, Spin to win.
Yeah, yeah.
The Dance of Knives skill in particular.
My favorite build.
It's awesome.
Yeah, I was really happy with where Dance of Knives landed as the new skill.
It found a lot of use in a variety of builds and people have a lot of fun playing with it.
We did notice a little bit of the melee-focused builds with Flurry and Twisting Blades falling behind
just a little bit.
So a few of our changes here are focused on enhancing the legendaries that talk to those
two, Encircling Blades and Blade Dancers.
In terms of key passives, we saw Victimized did have a bug that caused its damage scaling
to be higher than intended.
And so we have fixed that math calculation on how it kind of scales damage based on other
damage because it was really just a little bit too dominant.
And now we think with this update it'll still be a competitive choice, but it won't completely
outshine every other key passive on the Rogue.
And some nice little buffs here to Reign of Arrows just to make it work a little bit better
with Imbuement skills.
Love me some Reign of Arrows.
It's a very flashy skill, especially with all those colors with the Imbuements on it.
All right.
And finally, the Sorcerer.
The Sorcerer was definitely the strongest class I think we saw on the PTR by a fair margin.
Just a little bit.
It was quite strong.
People were having a lot of fun with Sorcerer builds, especially with the new key passive,
Enlightenment.
And Enlightenment had an issue where it's all about alternating skill casts.
Okay, you cast a Fire skill, you cast a Lightning skill, you cast a Cold skill, and you get these
stacks really quickly.
Unfortunately, it was stacking up unintentionally from some of those auto casts that we were
talking about earlier with Nature's Fury.
Where when you trigger bonus casts from like unstable currents, it was actually ramping up
the Enlightenment way too fast.
And so we fixed that interaction, but we think despite that, Enlightenment is still one of
the strongest key passives of sorts.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
So it just brings it down a little bit, but we still think this is going to be a really
powerful and compelling new key passive to play with once we go live.
Two other changes here with the Flame Scar and Oculus uniques.
This is kind of adding in this chance to deal double damage affixes for Incinerate and Teleport
respectively.
This harkens back to what I talked about on the PTR stream where we're adding these multiplicative
damage bonuses into tempering for weapons.
And of course we can't temper onto unique items, but for a lot of the unique items that
are about very specific skills such as Flame Scar and Oculus, we've taken a pass to add
in some of these affixes that enhance those skills in multiplicative ways to really make
sure that Incinerate gets the same benefit from using that unique as opposed to just a legendary
that you would temper this affix onto anyway.
It's a massive buff.
Yes.
Absolutely massive.
Incinerate size is like, I had to pull out a ruler like, is it actually...
Yeah.
Is it working?
Incinerate size and Teleport size maybe not the most compelling affix.
Now you just get some of this multiplicative damage.
If somebody wants to make an Oculus build where most of the damage comes from Teleport, that's
going to be awesome.
We'll see if you can manage to make that work.
Yeah, I love that idea.
Oh my god.
I already have a build page saved.
Ooh.
I'll have to see that.
Nice.
So yeah, once again, I just wanted to thank everyone for all the great feedback.
We on the class design team in particular are always reading and listening to feedback
on how you're playing the classes, what builds you're finding fun, what things are over or
underpowered.
We listen to it.
We read your feedback.
We watch the videos that you make.
We really appreciate all of it.
And it really helps us to make the game as best as possible.
Awesome.
Thank you so much, Charles, for walking us through all the changes coming for class design.
It's actually not all the changes that we saw right here.
As Charles mentioned, we do have patch notes actually going live after this stream.
And I will caveat, you will see 2.0.1 patch notes and you'll see 2.0.2 patch notes.
So there's 2.0.2 and 2.0.1.
2.0.2 is actually not on people's PCs yet.
You haven't preloaded that.
That is going to be the last update you'll need to grab before we jump into launch for Vessel
of Hatred.
So you'll get all the patch notes after the stream so you can dig through all the class
changes that we didn't cover and all the ins and outs of it between now and what we have
for PTR.
So last but not least, we have RuneWords.
So I think we're going to jump straight into it.
So Anthony, you want to go ahead?
Yeah, absolutely.
So again, awesome feedback.
We got lots of different things that came in.
And we've heard multiple times a couple different things with the RuneWords that really just,
people kept repeating over and over again.
Really, mostly stemming down to two major issues with the whole system.
And so previously, on the PTR, we had the legendary runes that were a lot stronger because you
want to reach that point eventually to where you get the powerful runes and then you play
the game that way.
Well, that was kind of outshining a lot of the other possibilities and like the idea that we had
with the runes where you're mixing and matching, creating different combinations.
So what we are ending up doing now is we are taking that top end and we're going to bring it down.
And then on the flip side, the second thing that we heard a lot of is those bottom runes,
those, I don't want to say bottom runes, the magic and rare runes that you find a little earlier,
especially those runes of ritual where you are, those are the ones where you're actually like
doing things to gain offering to then invoke those runes of invocation, those powers that you have.
Those were intentionally a bit lower so that you have some progress,
but it felt like when you get them, it wasn't enough.
You didn't get to really feel those runes happen and pop off when you get them.
So on the other side, we are taking that bottom end and bringing it up.
So together, we're kind of, I don't want to say flattening out, but we are making it a lot more
options for the players to really have choices throughout your whole journey rather than just
a linear, you know, get the stronger one. And then obviously it's stronger.
And what this will also do and the focus on this is to also make those utility runes really,
really potent and really pop off and a lot more visual things to happen.
And then finally, we removed a couple of runes that weren't quite meeting our expectations.
We have this thing that we say every once in a while, which is like condense the fun.
And we want to make that, you know, like the ideal situation where we have, you know,
the runes that we have are the ones that are cool and fun and not like overbloated with just a
bunch of things that don't, you know, don't always like meet those expectations.
Yeah. We want you to have lots of options and we don't want individual runes or effects to really
overshadow everything else. But that does mean that, you know, we want to make sure that all the
options are really compelling. And so ones that aren't meeting our bar, we just would rather take
them out rather than leave them in.
Yeah.
Absolutely.
I think we're always going to be adding to the rune system.
Of course.
So we want to leave ourselves the space. We didn't want to water down the pool with things
like the lightning bolt effect rune. It's like that didn't really have, it was an evolutionary
dead end. We didn't necessarily have any way to juice that up. So we want one of rune drops
for it to feel like, oh, there's this new toy I can play with. Right.
It's important that every choice in the rune system is meaningful. Like every, every possible
rune you can take or combination, like there's something there. Right.
Yeah. You want to feel it for sure. And it doesn't want to be something that, you know,
you just like, oh, I got this rune. And it's like, well, let me find another one.
All right. So here's some examples of some of the big outliers. We heard lots, lots of
feedback around these two, especially that war cry rune. So while it was giving berserking
to everyone, it was a big power bonus. And so we're going to bring that down a little
bit by just, it's no longer going to give that, that enhanced version. It's just the
baseline version. So it no longer gives berserking to all players. That does mean it still works
for barbarians because that is their skill. They should still be able to gain that power
as they would expect. And then down with the, the yam, which is that druid petrify,
the rune itself is not changing. What's actually changing is on druids themselves,
their ultimate there is no longer going to give that critical bonus baseline. It's not going to be
the enhanced version. So if you want that as a druid, you can still get that big, powerful,
critical damage bonus. But now that baseline is going to be that big stun, that big AOE moment that
you see everything on the screen freeze and also just juice you up with a bunch of resource. And
this is general, like class resource. So unlike what it'll say for the druid is it says their spirit
goes up. On the rune, it says it is your resource. So everyone gets this huge, big moment where you
can kind of reset. So if I'm a sorcerer, it doesn't generate spirit, it generates mana. Yes. You don't
just get a second bubble that fills up the spirit. That'd be weird. I like that this puts a lot more
emphasis on the utility of runes, which is sort of what we had been originally intending, right? Not
every choice is going to be a multiplicative damage source. So you should have a lot more options.
It's more focused on utility. Yeah, absolutely. And stealing other classes' power. Yeah, obviously,
multiplicative damage is probably the single strongest thing you can do in an ARPG. And
just when we noticed these ones were really those ones that are overshadowing every other
option, we still think those will find a great niche for the builds that want it, but they
won't be the only choice that no one else can use anything else for. Yeah, absolutely.
All right. So here's some examples. Again, I want to preface, this is not all of them.
There are a bunch of changes. You guys will see them in the patch notes as we had already
talked about. But some of the big ones that I wanted to show off here. So Spiritborn Vortex,
that's the one that pulls everyone in, you group everything together, that is going to be
almost, you're going to be able to get that almost twice as often as it was before. So
you combine that in with something that, you know, has some grindy damage in the middle, and
you're going to be just having this pop off all the time. As well as, so we call them subpowers.
Those are things like the sorcerer meteorites, or like the barbarian earthquakes, those things
that happen based on other things, but they create like another power that comes out. We are juicing
those up a lot more. So these should be some of the most powerful versions of these subpowers
in the game from these runes. And as you can see here, meteorites is jumping up a whole bunch,
as well as the offering cost is going down. So you're going to be able to summon a lot more
of these as well. And then one of the other things I saw feedback was around the say rune. I don't know exactly how to say it myself. I'll have to ask you a minute about that after this.
But where you summon spirit wolves, and they didn't feel as impactful because their AI was not as poppy as like say the Necromancers minions running around a lot more quickly. So we adjusted that, and so we're going to have a video coming up here in a second.
And we can see, so now you're going to summon those wolves, they're going to pop up and do their attack. And if you jump to the next pack, they're going to jump forward.
Except this is going to happen a lot more frequently than before. So now if you say fight that pack, jump to the next one, every time those wolves are going to just keep jumping and keep leaping.
And this works in ranged as well. So if you're fighting some enemy over here to the left, and you attack them, your wolves are going to jump immediately over there. And then if you switch to this other group on the right, those wolves are going to jump across the screen because we've also increased that aggro range as well for that.
Yeah, they feel a lot more responsive. And like, even in that clip, we saw them jump into the pack at basically the same time we did, right? They are right there with you. They're not lagging behind.
And that's always like the worst feeling when you're like, hey, some of this thing, where are they? What are they doing?
They're like, they're like, they're no longer lazy dogs.
Yeah, yeah, they were tired. They were tired.
Tired little pups, you know?
And then here are some examples of those runes of ritual. Again, those are the ones that are generating this offering. And so these are mostly going to be changes to those magic and rare runes, where we've taken that offering they give, and we've really knocked it up to be a lot closer to where those legendary versions of these are. And that should hopefully give us a lot more options when it comes to deciding which combination of which runes that we are using.
It also just means things are a lot more reliable. Like you're actually getting procs way more often with these buffs.
Yeah, you actually get to see the fun happen, right? See those effects happen a little bit more often.
Yeah, so tons of rune changes that are coming. And as Anthony mentioned, there's way more details in the actual patch notes themselves. So people can check that out after the stream, along with all the class changes, the system changes, the progression changes.
It's all detailed out there for players specifically.
You know, I had one thing, because I think we might have forgotten it. And, you know, I'm very concerned about monitor violence.
Oh, yes.
We heard a lot of people who wanted to punch and punch monitors.
Oh, that's right. Yes.
When you get a greater affects on impairment resistance.
Oh, yeah.
As monitor enthusiasts, we've just removed that from the affects pool.
Yes.
So, please don't.
Please don't.
Less punching of monitors.
Save the monitors, please.
And one thing I do want to call out on RuneWords. We actually, funny enough, we got a lot of feedback about players saying like, hey, we noticed like different art on some of the classic runes that they may have seen from like back in D2.
That art has been updated to match what you saw in D2.
So, Harkins back.
Yes.
That's cool.
Yeah.
Shout out to the history of runes there for everyone.
So, thank you guys for jumping into this.
And I will say like this team is going to be staying vigilant through the launch of Vessel of Hatred with our LiveOps teams here.
Shout out to our LiveOps team who will be helping us out through multitudes of patches, hot fixes.
We're going to be paying attention to the community and hearing all the feedback that players have.
And we'll be jumping on a lot of the big things that we do notice and we do want to jump like kind of address earlier on, especially right after launch.
So, our cadence is going to be quick.
So, do expect that.
We'll be posting all notes, all hotfix notes, etc.
Whenever they do come up.
So, thank you guys again for joining us today to talk about the PTR learnings.
Next up, we actually are going to start talking about the next season coming to Diablo 4, which is season six.
And that will actually start with the launch of Vessel of Hatred.
We're going to do another quick mic swap musical chairs thing.
Maybe we turn on Benny Hill music or something like that.
But we'll be right back here with our next group to talk about season six.
From technology.
Asiana Beach Hills.
We mojejama Monkey was they're going to Xu.
He went to Warsaw Water really neat.
Bell surprising Works was they were also going to pandemics.
My challenge is to catch them.
Let's go catch them over the next week.
They'll be right back in the northeast.
Changi Creek
The Shin outer Power F aiming at the Twin Excel Southernłemem ilim Team.
Elderly themed in來了 reference center inverneming and giraffe dimension across a simple decision.
The northam family Hawkации
The然 jemand community argues for making sure to save their nameажи the gift.
To teach them also answers, their saying how to choose their lips of fate.
And now if they are falling apart ringgrain, they're going to join形 republicans, something right in Turkey of this Manni Atl小illo
Thank you.
All right, we're back.
Sorry for that.
I'm glad you guys got to watch Dancing Demons and everything like that and see our release
date map.
But we're back here to talk about Season 6.
This is the new season coming with the launch of Vessel of Hatred and I'm joined by this
wonderful group here, Brent, who we already know, our game director here.
But Tim, Don, do you want to introduce yourselves?
Yes.
My name is Tim Ismay.
I am one of the lead producers on Diablo 4.
I mostly work on seasons.
I'm Don Adams.
I'm the lead season designer for Season 6, the season of Hatred Rising.
Also known as Content Supervisor.
There we go.
Awesome.
So, as Don just mentioned here, Season 6 is Season of Hatred Rising.
Tim, do you want to explain to us what Hatred Rising or Brent?
Yeah, I'll take this one.
So, when we started off with this, we really knew we wanted to make sure that we were launching
a brand new season right alongside Vessel of Hatred.
We wanted that to be day and date.
So, like, continuity was really important to us.
And so, the idea that the hatred of Mephisto and Nahantu is spilling out into the rest of
Sanctuary was kind of the anchor that we were holding on to.
And we started talking about what that would mean to make a whole season around that.
Awesome.
And I know with kind of, like, what players hearing Hatred Rising, they're hearing about,
you know, Mephisto and his hatred potentially leaking out into Nahantu, maybe the rest of Sanctuary.
Like, what can players expect with this actual season?
Yeah, so a lot of actually what is going to be the core of Season 6 and the Season 6 experience,
players have already gotten exposed to.
So, anybody who's playing on the PTR has been reading about the changes we put up there.
Fundamental to the release of Vessel of Hatred, Season 6 brings big changes where every single
class is going to gain access to new skill points.
They're going to gain new skills across all the classes.
They're going to gain more Paragon points, new Legendary Paragon glyphs.
These are all changes that are being added to the base of the game, meaning you do not
need to have Vessel of Hatred to gain access to these.
You also will still have access to these after Season 6.
These are permanent changes to the game.
On top of that, we got the standard new Legendary aspects.
We have new unique items and new Mythic items.
Crazy powerful Mythic items that are going to unlock just new levels of power that were
not possible before in the game.
Now, to go along with this power, we will be adding these new difficulty levels that again
we saw on PTR.
So, you have the ability to challenge these new levels of power.
I want to say that it's all going to even out well.
Honestly, despite the tireless efforts of our designers, just constant trying to get that
balance just right based on all the feedback that comes in, I know that maybe it'll be
out for a day before someone's posting a video and saying, oh, look at this, I do a trillion
damage.
And it'll go all over the internet.
Like, I've never seen numbers this big.
That's, yeah.
But we tried.
We tried to get it there.
You're going to see crazy builds.
Those are going to link into new difficulties that were never there before to try in all
this new content.
Yeah, awesome.
Yeah, I know all these things that players got to experience a little bit in PTR.
They got to see it.
They got to check it out early.
But, of course, there is more kind of associated with this specific season.
So, Don, do you want to talk a little bit more about what players can also see beyond
what Tim kind of walked through?
Yeah, absolutely.
So, you know, as we mentioned, this is the season of hatred rising.
So we really wanted to theme it around Mephisto's hatred creeping out of Nihantu and into the
rest of the world.
So let's go ahead and take a look at our visual aid here.
Beautiful.
Amazing.
I was promised.
Official documents.
I was promised that this would be turned into real art when I sent this over.
I didn't think we'd be showing this.
But hopefully this will all make sense by the end of the presentation.
Just for now, just take it in.
There you go.
Yeah.
Everyone loves designer art.
It's core to all our live streams that we do.
Art by Don Adams here.
Yeah.
And frankly, I think it speaks for itself.
I don't really know if there's much more to say.
But let's go ahead and go ahead and do the next slide here.
And let's take a look at some real art to get you ready for the season here.
This is, of course, amazing key art from Dave Raposa.
I just love kicking that demon in the face.
That makes me happy every time I see it.
Let's go ahead and move on to the next slide.
And I'll get into some actual details about how this stuff shows up in the world,
what you're going to be looking for when you're hunting these guys down.
So you're going to see these hatred rising zone events that cycle frequently throughout the world.
When these are up, everything in that area is going to be corrupted by hatred.
You're going to be seeing environmental changes, lighting changes.
The monsters will actually have, you know, kind of hatred gummy goop on them.
You can be ambushed from portals randomly.
And really all this is just setting the stage for the Realm Walker.
So you'll have a separate event icon that will let you know when the Realm Walker is going to be up.
It's a world event, so it will be in that list on the map with, you know,
other, like, world bosses and Legion events and stuff.
And we have some video here to kind of show you what it looks like.
Oh, actually, I think we have another slide about the Realm Walker first.
Sorry.
Yeah, so this is what he looks like in-game.
He's awesome.
These are just big, hulking kind of monstrosities stomping around, you know,
just spreading Mephisto's hatred.
They summon in monsters from a plane of hell through this portal on their back.
And a lot of the monsters they summon, most of them are actually new monsters from Vessel of Hatred.
They're the Hollows family, which are super cool and gross.
So I think now we can take a look at what it actually looks like in-game.
So here's some players waiting for him to spawn.
He starts Burrowed like that, and you can kind of click the portal to summon some stuff to fight while you're getting warmed up here.
I just love these enemies.
They're so cool, the Hollows.
So he busts out of the ground.
And this is actually, we want to do something new with this event and lean into the fantasy of this giant thing just like stomping around.
So it's actually a walking world event.
He has several different paths you can take throughout each area.
He walks through the zone.
And as he walks, he just leaves this, you know, chaos behind him in his wake.
He's summoning tons of Hollows.
And, you know, if you get in front of him, he just punts you out of the way and keeps going.
You actually can't even damage him directly in this phase.
But if you kill enough of the adds that he's spawning, it'll create these bloodbound guardians.
Killing these will shave some of the HP off of the Realm Walker.
So when he reaches the end of his path and you can actually fight him, you'll have, you know, less HP to burn through.
So this is a nice way to incentivize actually, you know, participating, sticking around for all this chaos.
Obviously lots of XP and whatnot from the mobs as well.
So this is the event that he kicks off when he actually gets to his destination.
When you interrupt this ritual by destroying all of these destructible hatred spires,
that's when you'll actually be able to fight him directly.
And I think we're going to see that here very quickly.
This is a really cool encounter.
There's just lots of, you know, he has a big smashy attack.
He sprays a lot of damage everywhere.
Okay, so they've taken him down.
And when he dies, that weird portal on his back drops down and stays open.
And there's only really one thing to do with a weird portal.
Yeah, you go in the portal.
It's your option.
So that's what portals are made for.
Successfully killing the Realm Walker, taking down this massive demon,
finally grants you your reward of more demons.
So you're going to go into the Seething Realm.
This is part of the Mephisto's area of hell.
So you are going to have to continue fighting in here.
It is not a barren landscape.
But the demons you fight in here, comparatively,
if you were strong enough to take down a Realm Walker, don't be too worried.
I think you're going to be able to manage the demons inside of the Seething Realm as well.
This dungeon is a little bit more of a reward dungeon.
So once you get in here, you're fighting your way through to get specific buffs at the end of it.
So if we want, we can jump into the video here.
Yeah, this is the first section.
And this part, you're just kind of mowing through some of these smaller guys.
You're really just looking for a specific gate here.
There's a portal that you're going to be activating and making an important choice there
about which section of the Seething Realm you go into.
Here it is.
This is the gate here.
So you're going to click on this.
You now have options.
Based on a few consumables that you can put in,
you can go into sections that are more focused on equipment bonus, gold bonus.
You can get a socketable bonus.
You can get more endgame items with like compasses and boss materials.
So you're going to pick one of these and decide that's the section I want to go into.
You're going to get some drops similar to that in this section of the dungeon.
But more importantly, this is going to set you up for the type of buff you want to get at the end of the dungeon.
So again, this is not an empty area.
You are going to have to fight through it.
You're going to encounter more hollows in here, some more elites.
All of this leading up to a chest at the end.
Here is your reward.
So finally, you just click on this.
You get your reward.
Ah, just kidding.
Yeah, of course it's a curse event.
Of course.
You're going to have to fight even more demons.
Nothing's free in hell.
This is just how you got to do it.
So you fight your way through some more elites.
But don't worry.
I believe in you.
You can get through this.
If you kill the last guy.
There's one more there.
Take him down.
Come on.
All right.
So he goes down.
Now you get your prizes.
You're going to open these chests.
There's a variety of loot that you get.
But one specific item that you're looking for in here.
Which is going to be a seething opal.
So these little.
There they are.
Yeah, little seething opals.
They got a little seasonal marker on them.
This is special to season six.
When you get these.
I'm going to take a look here.
This is going to be a buff you get.
Based on the one that you chose.
There are some fundamentals you always get.
So a seething opal always gives you a 15% bonus to experience.
This is especially cool because it stacks with elixirs.
You can have an elixir and a seething opal active at the same time.
That's a huge bonus.
On top of that.
Any seething opal that you use is going to allow you to now get reputation with the remnants of the Zaku room.
Don will talk about that more in just a second.
But that's going to be the reputation track for season six.
And then beyond that you will get a bonus depending on which portal you went through.
Which section of the Seething Realm you decided to go into.
Here we go.
Yeah, if you want to snapshot this.
Anybody who's screenshotting.
These are some of the bonuses you can get.
As you can see on here you're getting maybe more items.
Maybe more gold.
More socketables.
So these bonuses are going to occur while fighting anything while having this buff active.
So equipment as an example.
Maybe I wanted more items to be dropping.
When you kill monsters there's a chance that they're going to drop a cache.
That is going to give you some additional loot.
And if you're playing content in let's say further in the end game.
That monsters don't traditionally drop loot.
Not to worry.
We've adjusted that as well.
If you play through the pit as an example.
We have added an additional drop at the end of the pit.
Again that procs based on which Seething Opal that you chose.
There are a couple up here at the end.
Oh the socketable one I should mention.
That one is special too.
You do have to have Vessel of Hatred for that one.
This one is more for people that are trying to get more runes.
So obviously you need to have Vessel of Hatred to get runes.
So that's what's going to make this valuable to you.
It's cool to also see like boss summoning items on here.
Infernal Compasses as well.
Infernal Compasses themselves are going to be very valuable.
Because it's as Colin was mentioning before.
We saw what you can end up getting in Infernal Hordes and everything like that.
It's just another opportunity to get more compasses for getting in there.
Yeah Seething Opal of Tormant I think is great.
I think that grape flavored opal is going to be very popular.
The grape one is going to be pretty popular.
And a question I just quickly solved.
Because you mentioned stacking with Elixirs.
Does it also stack with Incense?
Yeah it will stack with Incense.
There you go.
So that's a triple stack of XP right there.
You get a lot of experience.
Which is actually really cool.
So that's awesome.
So obviously like you know we're seeing the rewards here.
And one thing that you had mentioned which was the Zack Room remnants.
Like what Don can you like talk to us a little bit.
About kind of what that progression track is going to be.
Yeah sure.
So these are the Zack Room remnants.
You've probably seen these guys in Hawazar.
These are the Crusaders with the rusty armor.
That have just been kind of bombing around.
Since they you know they failed to find Akarat's tomb.
They have a very personal connection with Mephisto.
You know he of course destroyed basically the Zack Room order many years ago.
And at this time they're still just not really ready to stand up.
And fight this at full force right.
They've been dealing with cultists.
And they're just not at their full strength.
So you'll meet this Crusader right at the start of the season.
Who will give you a very simple intro quest basically.
To guide you to kill a Realmwalker.
Clear a seething realm.
And he'll be your point of contact for reputation rewards following that.
So you know basically we built this in a way that.
With the Opals giving rep for all sorts of different activities.
The idea is that you can you know go and kind of do whatever you want to do.
As long as you're checking in periodically with the Realmwalker.
And keeping a stack of these Opals on hand.
It's very open ended how you want to push this reputation track.
Yeah it is always nice to see that.
Anywhere that new demons occur in the world.
There is always some faction out there that's trying to take care of them.
And would appreciate your help.
So the Zoccero here they've had a rough go of it.
But if you can help them out I think that we can handle this problem.
And they're not at their best right now.
Yeah.
You know one of the things that I really like about the way we've looked at this whole package.
Is that not only have we done a bunch of diligence in making sure that the story is taking part in all of Sanctuary.
We're touching on some really cool lore stuff that has existed for a long period of time.
But we're also leaning into a theme of giving the players more control over the experience.
And so whether it's the choice of reward or being able to stack these rewards to get specific outcomes.
You're going to see that not only in the season.
So everybody's going to get access to this in the season.
But we have that theme also creeping into some of the stuff you'll see with the Vessel of Hatred content in just a few minutes.
Yeah.
So hopefully the hieroglyphs that we saw at the beginning.
The designer.
Hopefully this makes sense now.
You kill the Realm Walker to get the portal.
You do the portal to get the opals.
And then you go do the MS Paint sort of shapes of all the other activities that are in the game.
You can also just chain run the Realm Walker if you'd like as well.
He's up very often.
And I expect people will kind of go back and forth on how often they're interacting with them.
You might want to stack a bunch of opals for the weekend or something.
If you hate Realm Walkers and you're like, I just want to kill Realm Walkers all day, you can.
What I love about the season is exactly that.
You can get the opal.
It's a great buff.
And now go play other content, including the new content that's coming out in Vessel of Hatred if you bought the expansion.
Got a lot of options there.
So you don't have to just play the seasonal content.
You'll play this other stuff while still having the buff.
Including the Vessel of Hatred campaign, which is kind of a first, right?
You'll need to have completed the base campaign.
But you can play the Vessel of Hatred campaign alongside the Season 6 content, which is pretty cool.
Yeah, so huge for people that have base game or Vessel of Hatred can partake in the content for this season.
Don, Tim, thank you guys for walking us through all the Season of Hatred Rising content that's coming with the launch of Vessel of Hatred.
This is starting right at the beginning, right when Vessel of Hatred actually comes out, which is on, again, October 7th at 4 p.m.
For some people.
4 p.m. Pacific time, which is for everyone because it is one global release.
It'll be the 7th for me.
Yeah, 7th for us here in California.
But for other people, if you follow time zones, that's what it'll end up being.
So we'll see Tim Moore during our Q&A at the end.
But we are actually going to jump into some of the Vessel of Hatred features next.
We're going to do another musical chair as Benny Hill style.
Swap out some mics and everything.
But we have a lot to talk about.
We got Spiritborn stuff to talk about.
We got Cur-Ass Undercity.
Or Cur-Ass Undercity to talk about.
Well, I've been doing that quite often this week.
Dark Citadel and, of course, Mercenary.
So we'll be back with a whole new crew here in just a couple minutes.
Let's go.
To be continued...
Thank you.
Season Designer, and I'll be chatting about the Kuros Underseeding in a few.
Bjorn? Bjorn Mikkelsen, Class Designer
for Spirit Porn. Hi, I'm Dan Brace. I'm a Lead Game Designer, and I'll
be talking about Mercenaries. Awesome. Cool. So, you know, tons
of content coming to Vessel of Hatred. I know
players have heard us talk about it a little bit, but Brent,
did you want to talk about any content specifically before we jump in?
Yeah, I mean, just kind of teeing up the next big thing that we want to talk
about is just kind of how well the Spirit Born reaction has been since we've
announced it. It's been amazing to see folks so
excited about it. It's something that we've been pouring a lot of love into. We wanted to
make sure they were adding something fresh to the game, and I really feel like we're there.
But, when we released it, we actually still had work to do.
And so, throughout the PTR
and the last few weeks of development
here, we've been putting a lot of effort into polishing
things up, and I'm super excited
to hear Bjorn talk about what we've got in store.
Yeah, lots of internal testing. We have players
actually check it out at Gamescom
as well, which was really cool. So,
as we all know, Bjorn
was on our Spirit Born reveal
stream, and he's back to talk
more about Spirit Born. So, here
is Spirit Bjorn
to talk more about the Spirit Born.
It's hard for me to actually say Spirit
Born now, because I just say Spirit Bjorn. So, there we go.
Awesome. Yeah. Yes, I mean, we've seen a lot of the sort of in development side of it, and we're just going to talk about a few kind of final touches, the final version of a few things that we want to hit on quickly here in this presentation.
So, starting off, we're going to talk about a couple of updates to the Spirit Born's passives.
First off, we have three additional passives which have been added to the tree.
Each of these kind of amplifies how the skills work that they relate to. So, we have one for core skills, one for potency skills, and one for focus skills.
And that sort of lets you kind of go more all-in on any of those skills.
There's also here on the far side of the slide an update to Noxious Resonance, which is one of Spirit Born's key passives.
We really wanted to kind of clarify how this mechanic works, how it scales, and kind of answer some lingering questions about exactly how it works.
But it's still largely based around exploding the poisons on your enemies.
Moving on to another thing, we're going to have a small update to the Jaguar primary Spirit Hall.
This will still do lots of damage whenever you spec into it. It's all about damage with the Jaguar.
But this has focused it a little bit more about multi-attack skills, high attack speed, and really allowing you to ramp up the damage that you can get it.
Because now it's also based around the damage that you did in a short window.
So, that lets you sort of echo all of that damage that you did the faster you're attacking.
Moving on to another small, or sort of medium-sized update.
There was some confusion around Spirit Feathers, Storm Feathers, the Eagle Hall, how all that kind of works together.
So, this has been unified into a new concept just called Storm Feathers.
What this is, is this is a buff that you can get. This increases your movement speed, and it stacks duration.
And now all of these things, they all speak to the Storm Feather concept.
So, you can get them, you can modify them, you can make them do different things.
And you can even use it to make kind of some crazy builds.
I think we have a video for it, where you can just kind of have feathers going all over the place as you're doing it.
And you can even use like tempering and various paragon that increases Storm Feather potency.
That will speak to all of these aspects, as well as the Eagle Primary Hall.
And then, moving on to the last thing we've got, should be our Uniques.
So, some of you might have gotten to see some early versions of these.
But we want to kind of show off the final versions with all of their stats and all of their glory.
So, to start off, we have six unique Spirit-Born Rings.
Each of these kind of emphasizes a combination of two Spirits.
And really lets you sort of tailor how you generate your resource.
To sort of make the build that you're looking to make.
Then, moving on to our Unique Armors.
We showed off the Scorn of the Earth Boots that turns your Soarin' to Evade.
And everybody really loved that.
A couple other examples.
We've got Craze of the Dead God, which allows you to turn all damage coming at you into poisoning damage.
And then sort of throw that back out at your enemies in the form of Touch of Death.
Which is pretty neat.
And then we've also got our Helms.
We have two different Unique Helms.
One is focused more along the lines of letting you sort of mix and match Spirits.
While the other one is more about kind of doubling down on using a single Spirit.
And then finally, we have our Unique Weapons.
We've got several Glaives and Quarterstaffs.
We already showed off the basic one.
But we're going to quickly show off sort of its counterpart, which is the one for your Core Skills.
So this one allows you to sort of spam your Core Skills almost as if they were basics.
That sort of reduced damage.
But when you're at maximum vigor, it ramps up to be a maximum size, guaranteed crit, just massive screen clearing version of the Core Skill.
So we think that one's pretty fun too.
And then lastly, I believe I have a slide just for, yeah, there we go, our drop tables for the bosses.
So if you're looking to target farm any of these specific ones similar to the other classes, you can kind of farm these based on different bosses.
So take a screenshot of this and go for it.
Awesome.
Yeah, tons of updates.
I mean, we've done so much internal testing.
We've heard a lot of feedback because we have that deep dive blog.
We've seen people theory craft.
We've seen people actually play it at Gamescom.
We've had a couple of content creators like during the Spirit Porn live stream.
And even during our like kind of a preview event, they actually got to try it out and stuff.
So hearing all this feedback and then, you know, applying some of the feedback and some of the internal feedback that we ended up getting and seeing all the changes here and updating everyone has been really cool to see.
So thank you again, Bjorn, for walking us through the Spirit Porn.
The class is incredibly fun.
Day one is what I'm planning for Vessel of Hadrian.
I think most of us are.
But yeah, it's a ton of fun to check out.
Next up, what we wanted to talk about is Cure Asunder City.
This is actually a feature that we did announce with Gamescom.
But we didn't really get a ton of opportunities to really kind of like dive deeper into what Cure Asunder City is.
So Derek, you want to take us through this?
Yeah, absolutely.
So the Cure Asunder City is a brand new dungeon experience that players, our Vessel of Hatred players, will be unlocking throughout the course of the campaign.
It's appropriately located in the new capital city of Cure Ast, but it's the part of town that's not recommended that the standard citizen will venture into.
It's a section of the Kuros town that is still infested by the jungles of Nahantu and kind of overrun with the worst of the worst.
It's Nahantu's most wanted inside the various districts that make up the Undercity.
Throughout the course, as players are unlocking it, they'll meet a new character named C-Heck that kind of teaches you the laws of the Undercity and how to commune with the Spirit Flames to traverse its treacherous depths, basically.
So that's kind of like the narrative setting for it, but let's dive into the actual experiential standpoint, which we see here already.
So the Cure Asunder City is an intense multi-floor time attack dungeon where players will be racing against an aggressive countdown timer to reach the district boss with as high of a rewards upgrade meter built up as possible and try not to let that timer expire.
So fun little novel wrinkle here is that killing certain monsters we refer to as afflicted will give you time bonuses to extend your time in the Undercity.
And just killing monsters in general and completing dungeon activities will build up this reward upgrade meter referred to in-game as attunement.
As far as the Undercity's role, it's one novel, new novel leveling content, but its power really comes into the fact that it's brand new opportunistic content that allows players to make very efficient, very specific progress towards rewards goals as the opportunities arise.
I'll dive deeper into that in the next few slides, but for now, just want to kind of set the stage that the Undercity does not necessarily have any objective aside from get to the boss, beat the clock, and do so with the highest amount of rewards upgrades built up as possible.
How the players go about doing that is entirely up to them because this is a dungeon that celebrates autonomy, flow, and variety.
This is a good example we were talking about earlier when we're looking at the new modes that we have.
We want that player agency to come back to the player.
Play your way.
And I think this is a perfect example of that.
Yeah, absolutely.
So let's dive into the next slide here.
Cool.
So I mentioned opportunistic content, and this is where the Undercity's primary role in the reward structure is.
So we have dungeon keys that grant you access to dungeons.
The Undercity's version of a dungeon key is in the form of tributes.
So you can hop into an Undercity run without a tribute, just do the thing, the base run.
But when you start applying tributes, this is where we allow you to define the specific reward upgrade opportunities of your next Undercity run at the cost of increasing the runs challenge.
So you can see an example of a tribute here.
This is the Tribute of Radiance.
And when you slot this in, so long as you complete your Undercity run with at least Attunement Rank 1, we will guarantee that you get Ancestral Legendaries at the end.
We'll dive a little bit deeper into some of the nuances.
You can see that it has dungeon affixes that define the specific challenge.
So the higher and more powerful the tribute, the tougher the challenge is in the form of lower starting time, time bonus penalties, and potion drop penalties.
But the fun doesn't really stop there.
In fact, we're just getting started.
Once you apply a tribute, you now unlock the ability to define a bargain.
Each tribute has a list of bargains mapped to it.
So this Tribute of Radiance has a collection of them.
We're just picking out a couple that seem pretty fun to show off.
And bargains allow you to further customize your rewards at a varying material cost.
So we have one here, skill ranks.
Legendary armors will always possess at least one skill rank affix for X amount of gold here.
And then the passive ranks, which you'll see a little bit more later, the legendary amulets will always possess at least one passive rank affix.
So let's go into the next slide just to, again, recap the full flow.
And we're going to see a video of all this to let it all kind of like soak in and see like the full flow of the undercity.
So we have the front end experience where you interact with the spirit brazier.
You can jump directly into your district run or you can optionally apply a tribute and then a bargain to specify the rewards opportunity of your next run.
So let's go see this in action.
Look at that.
So this is the hub of the undercity and that's the spirit brazier that I was mentioning.
You can see that we have the base, you know, the base run rules, you know, starting time, no time bonus penalties, no potion drop penalties.
And we have the opportunity to apply a tribute.
We have four tributes here.
So, you know, we'll show these in a still shot later so you don't have to like worry about, oh, what does it say?
But we have four tributes here that range from magic all the way to unique to, you know, accommodate your leveling journeys.
So for now, we applied the legendary tribute that will guarantee ancestral uniques at the end of your run.
And again, this is the list of potential bargains that I mentioned that each tribute has.
Each tribute has like varying quantities of bargains attached to it.
So we're going to pick the passive rank legendary amulets for the low, low price of 50 million gold.
The spirit flame services don't come cheap, but they're worth it.
So we got the portal open and we're going to hop into the run.
We're going to have this play a couple of times.
First, I just want to point out the HUD because this is really kind of your guide to the experience.
So you can see at the top, once we exited that spirit aura, the timer starts.
And that's a nice little, you know, timer at the top right hand corner of your screen.
We also display the number of floors that you have, you know, left to traverse.
Very key information right there.
To the right hand side of the objective tracker, we have the attunement meter and it's segmented into four ranks.
Again, as I mentioned, achieving rank one is the bare minimum requirement necessary to get the value of the tribute that you slotted in.
All subsequent ranks further enhance the value of that reward.
So while you certainly want to strive to get, you know, attunement rank four to maximize your payout, it's not necessary if you're feeling the pinch of, you know, the time pressure.
That if you at least get attunement rank one, you can, you know, run it to the boss room and still come away with the thing that you're looking for.
So I'm going to point out a couple of things here.
You might have seen, let's do the spirit beacon.
So the spirit beacon is one of our activity types and completing it both gives you attunement, a good splash of attunement.
And it applies a momentary, you know, spirit buff that increases your movement speed and reduces your, was it the skill cooldowns.
Again, you got to move fast in the inner city.
So these spirit beacons are incredibly useful for getting you to the next location, whether it's another spirit beacon or the exit.
We're also kind of showing here the lesser afflicted.
As you can see, you know, they're clearly marked in the game world.
They're all, you know, orangey, glowy, so you can, you know, keep your focus on the combat.
And killing them is what gives you the time bonuses to extend your run.
I think that's kind of the long and short of the inner city run.
Again, this is an example of floor one.
There's still two more floors to traverse to get to the boss room.
But yeah, let's hop up.
There we go.
We're into the boss room.
So in this case, we have finished all three floors.
We made it to the boss room.
One thing you'll notice that time expiration, it stops.
Time drain stops in the boss room.
So you just need to make it to the boss room before that timer hits zero.
This is Aaliyah, one of our three district bosses.
And it's important to call out that there are three total districts to explore in the inner city.
Again, that's tapping into the variety aspect of things.
So Aaliyah is, again, just one of three henchmen that own the various districts.
So in this case, we're at the tail end of this fight.
We just, you know, killed Aaliyah.
And we see that we ended this run with a full reward upgrade of four.
So now we're going to get the best possible payout for this.
And we came in here looking for ancestral legendaries.
And as the spirit flames promised, ancestral legendaries is what we get.
And, you know, the greater affixes.
And we also see that we got an amulet.
If we were to dive into, like, the amulet, we would have seen that the bargain would have applied to it as well.
So the player would have gotten specifically what they came in here for.
So that's a really quick snapshot of just, like, the structure of an under city flow.
I want to take this time just to dive into a little bit more details on the tributes that we saw in the gameplay footage and spend a little bit more time with them.
So this is an example of four of our eight total tributes.
These are hand-selected primarily just to showcase how the tributes are tuned to progress with your leveling journeys.
So we start off here with the tribute of growth.
This is usable in all difficulty levels.
This is the tribute that rewards additional experience when you complete the under city.
So this is great, you know, for leveling up your alts, leveling up your character in general.
And you can see here that we start applying the first of the, you know, I guess penalties or challenges for this
in the sense that we have lower starting time.
We actually incur a time bonus penalty now.
And we have potion drop penalties.
Something also to note is, you know, this is just found randomly in Sanctuary.
So as you're just doing your standard leveling stuff like the hell tides or whatever,
you will get these types of tributes to say, you know, point you to the under city every now and again.
So let's go back to the tribute gallery, as I like to call it.
Can we go back to that last slide that we had up there?
There we go.
Yeah.
All right.
Cool.
Thank you.
And then we get to, from there, it just gets progressively more challenging,
but also progressively more rewarding for the players.
So tribute of harmony rewards guaranteed runes.
This is a torment tier difficulty.
And you can see, you know, we just amp up the challenge with each one.
The tribute of radiance is the one that we just saw in action that we guaranteed ancestral legendaries.
And the tribute of ascendance is example of kind of like the cream of the crop tribute,
unique tribute that guarantees several uniques with an increased chance of a mythic unique.
And I just want to call it out here that I know that the last two tributes say that, you know,
they're resolute tributes and they only, you know, apply rewards to the player that offered it.
We do have variants of both of these that work in party.
So that, you know, hole is covered.
The rest of the tributes that don't have that distinction, they reward everyone in the party.
It's just these last two that, you know, kind of had that little, you know, asterisk on it.
So, yeah, I think that's the gallery of the tributes.
And again, these are mapped to, the rest of them are mapped to a variety of content like the whisper caches,
the summoned lair bosses, and a variety of things that I'm forgetting on the spot here.
Yeah, this is a fantastic activity to do when you're somewhat in the mid game of your journey.
So you're going to be introduced to this as you're making your way through the campaign.
And, but the thing I like about it is with all the progression changes that we've been looking at,
this also scales with you.
And so this is the type of activity that's going to stick with you for a while.
It's a great way to get control over looking for the items you're looking for.
And the time attack feature of this is really great.
Yeah.
And I think the big thing here is like you can do it solo or you can do it with a group.
So it's not like you have other options if you want to bring in a full party
or if you'd like to just conquer it yourself.
And I know a lot of people in chat are going like, hey, 50 million for all that.
There are, I'm not sure if you guys saw all the different bargains and everything.
There's a plethora of different costs for a lot of different options.
And depending on what you're looking for, you can obviously target specific things.
You may specifically want, you know, uniques or something like that.
And that like chaotic uniques, I think, had like an oval requirement or whatever.
So there's a lot of different bargain options for players to get.
And if you are looking for specific rewards, you have an additional avenue to do so,
which is really cool with Curious Undercity.
So, yeah.
Awesome.
Cool.
Well, there we go.
I think there's more, actually.
We're not doing it.
It's the best prices.
Yeah.
The Curious Undercity is the gift that keeps on giving.
So, one additional activity that you'll discover as you're, you know, romping through the Undercity
is our Undercity unique Treasure Goblin, the Portal Prankster.
We'll show some gameplay footage in just a moment.
But first, I just want to, you know, call out killing him will reward a bonus chest at the end of the dungeon.
And in addition, that contains just standard, you know, Treasure Goblin loot, runes, and more tributes.
So it's a really good, very juicy reward to go after the Portal Prankster when you come across him.
But you would be doing so at your own peril because you'll see in this video that he has a particular mechanic to him
that makes it a little bit tricky when you have a continually timer that's continually counting down.
So you'll see here that when he's aggroed, he opens up a bunch of portals and just like Benny hills through them.
It's a chase.
So this is kind of tapping into the risk versus reward nature of the Undercity
where you make decisions based on how confident you are at the current state of your run.
And again, killing him is very lucrative.
He doesn't drop anything aside from attunement right from the get-go.
But all of his rewards are funneled at the end of the experience.
So again, a variety of the spice of life in the Undercity.
And just, yeah, really excited to get this into the hands of players.
Yeah, it's cool to see a new goblin variant right there.
And then, of course, you know, the ultimate troll goblin, as you can see in the gameplay.
And that's the risk reward you were talking about.
Like, do you spend the time chasing after this specific goblin as it's bouncing between different portals,
as your time is ticking down and you're trying to progress and get better rewards?
And, of course, if you succeed and you get everything, you get that extra chest at the end, which is really awesome.
Yeah, it's worth it.
Yeah, most definitely is worth it, especially since you get so much progress added once you do actually take down the goblin as well.
So thank you, Derek, for walking us through this.
We have a bunch of seats here.
We actually have a non-physical seat here because we do actually have one other person that we're going to be tapping into to talk to us about the Dark Citadel.
And this is Mr. Jason Bentley, who is live via satellite.
I'm going to, yeah, that's what I'm going to say, satellite.
From the East Coast, Jason is our lead raid designer on Dark Citadel.
And, Jason, do you want to talk to us a little bit about it?
Absolutely.
Thanks for having me.
As you heard, I'm the lead for the Dark Citadel.
And we're going to talk about Rise of the Khazra.
This is the very first multiplayer-focused piece of content for Diablo 4.
This page.
So, as you can kind of guess, this whole thing is about essence and souls and sealing them and owning them and just using it as power.
Go ahead.
So, why are we here?
We're here to fight the first Khazra.
They are taking over the crater left from the Mage Clan Civil War, blasted a hole into the ground, and they've moved in.
And they're using all the souls from the dead clan, dead Mage Clan people to power their crazy experiments.
They're really, really evil.
They are taking people.
They take their own kind.
And they turn them into, like, power sources and batteries.
And they use them.
And they're all about resurrecting their dead god, Zagral.
This all takes place in, or starts in Nihantu.
You start out the whole quest line in Kuras.
They're going to tell you how bad this is.
They really don't like having their friends and family stolen and taken and drained and having Huss returned.
So, you're going to go on a quest to go find out what's happened to these people and see if you can go help.
A lot of other heroes have actually tried this, and they have all failed.
So, really, when you get through this entire experience, what you really come back with is only together can we prevail.
We need to bring some friends with you to come to this content.
You're not going to be able to do it on your own.
Once you get through all of this, this actually only happens at Torment 1.
So, this is not an early leveling experience.
This is something when you're really into the game and you really need to, like, move your build along.
So, once you enter Torment 1, you can go on this quest and access the Ancient Nexus, which is its own town space with a waypoint of all of its own,
which gives access to the three dungeons you can see here.
These dungeons have multiple boss fights in each one, and they each take a little bit of time to get through.
Practice will help you optimize these runs.
Experience will help you show expertise in shepherding other people to show them how to complete these mechanics.
And communication is not required, but it definitely leads to better outcomes.
There's a lot of new challenges in mechanics, and there's really no mercy for the hardcore players.
So, you have to be good, too.
As you can see right now, we've actually got one party split across two different realms, doing different mechanics and helping each other, and coming back together to bring down the boss.
It really takes at least two players to do these mechanics.
We have multiplayer boss fights through the entire experience, and we always say the players are stronger together.
It's tuned for four players.
Two players can do these mechanics, but it means you have to handle the mechanics and the monsters and the bosses by yourselves.
We're not going to duck the difficulty for fewer players.
We have lots of crazy mechanics going on.
We've got people relying on each other to get through all of this.
There's a lot of hero moments in this content.
The best moments we had when we were playtesting this is somebody's dead, and the other person's running around, and they click the switch, or they res the other friend right in time to jump through the portal or kill the boss.
And everyone's just screaming and having a great time.
It's really, really fun to work together and see those moments where, depending on your party members, really pays off.
We also have an exclusive monster family for the Dark Citadel.
These are the newest, smartest monsters you have met.
These are the first Kazura.
They're pretty evil people.
Shout out to the first Kazura monster family team.
They did a great job on all of these guys.
They are awful.
They're decadent.
They're sophisticated.
They use a lot of magic.
They do a lot of crazy things to bring down the party.
These are cool-looking enemies.
That's for sure.
I know with at least Dark Citadel, of course, there's always awesome rewards that are associated with this.
Jason, do you want to talk to us a little bit about those?
Absolutely.
I think we have that queued up.
Yeah.
Let's see if we can get that queued up here.
The joys of...
Well, we do have...
We did it.
Oh, actually, a quick quality of life improvement here.
We actually have a marker system to help parties get through the experience.
You can just drop them into your emote wheel.
And then as you're running through the experience, you can use those emotes to indicate to your friends and party members,
Hey, I found something of interest.
Or, Hey, it's over here.
This is the way forward.
And a really nice thing is this is available outside the Citadel as well.
It's not exclusive.
So you'll be able to use this wherever you go with your party.
We also have a combat log during the Citadel experience to help you understand what's happening,
especially where you're taking damage from in big moments.
And you've heard about the Party Finder.
That's also created with, obviously, Citadel in mind, but it supports everybody else.
But we want to make sure we facilitate getting lots of people into this content.
Hopefully now we can talk about rewards.
Well, before we jump into that, I do want to make mention,
because that was a really interesting screen to see the communication stuff and talking about Party Finder.
One of the things that we've seen since launch is that our cooperative player basis is growing.
You know, it's growing steadily.
And so we wanted to make sure that we did a couple of things.
First off, we wanted endgame content for them, right?
That's what this is all about, is making sure that we have that really aspirational endgame content
for folks who like to play with their friends.
The other thing is that we know that we could let this spread out into more segments of the game.
And so the Party Fighter was originally a discussion that we had for how to support the Dark Citadel.
But it is now benefiting all the other activities in our game as well.
So for those of you who have experienced, you're seeing the early stages of us really expanding,
getting people together in the content that is the best inside of the game.
And so it's really exciting.
But it does boil down to that communication, and that marker system is something that can be both used in the Citadel
as well as outside of the Citadel.
And I think that that's going to be really valuable for accessibility for a lot of folks out there.
Yep, that's definitely.
All right, now on to rewards.
Now we'll talk rewards.
Sorry, had to get that in there.
Absolutely.
So you're actually chasing a weekly reward that resets on the Tuesday or the day of the week that we set.
So really, that's going to drop a massive ancestral loot drop each time you pop that open,
which only happens when you complete all three dungeons.
You're going to want to chase that thing.
That is a huge, important drop for a week.
But beyond that, there's lots of rewards for repeated runs.
The Citadel coins are going to allow you to purchase all these consumables,
and you can maximize the number of coins you get per run by killing treasury monsters and playing on higher difficulties.
Like, it really scales up the Citadel coins you get.
And why do you care about those?
Well, A, these consumables really make it easier and more fun to play with groups and parties.
But it also allows purchase of the Scroll of Restoration.
So if you want to just chase down and buy scrolls, this is a great place to do that.
Sick slide for a production right there.
We're doing this live, right?
Yeah, exactly.
No, that's actually really cool to see.
And again, the Scroll of Restoration being a reward in Dark Citadel.
And like what we talked about earlier, you actually do get two guaranteed ones in the Season Journey.
And at the same time, those are something that you can find all around the world.
But Dark Citadel is also just like that guaranteed way of being able to get it as well.
So there's a lot of different variety of rewards.
But it goes beyond what we just showed right there.
There's actually some really, really cool stuff as well that I know Jason wants to show off us.
Absolutely.
I would love to end up on just the way everyone can show off their ability to just play this content to the top levels.
So we're going to show you our premier gear.
There's actually two levels of gear that you can get from playing the Dark Citadel.
There's the normal level gear, which you'll get from Torments 1 through 3.
And it's pretty accessible.
But what you're seeing right now is our premier content, which comes from only completions in Torment 4.
So I hope this is as exciting for everyone to get as I'm excited to give it to you.
So I'll see you in the Citadel.
And thank you for letting me show this off.
Awesome.
Thank you so much, Jason.
To this mount.
Go back to the mount.
I know you were probably like, oh, we've got to scroll through everything.
But, oh, okay.
There we go.
The mount is sick.
Oopsie.
Scroll through.
There we go.
Do it live.
Okay.
Yeah.
The mount is sick.
That's something that I think a lot of people are going to be kind of like chasing after for sure with the Dark Citadel.
Jason, thank you so much for walking us through that.
Really excited for it.
And what's cool is like, as Jason mentioned, Dark Citadel itself, you can do it with a group of four.
You can even attempt to go for two people.
If you're really skilled, you have that option of being able to do it.
The Party Finder feature now being part of the game now.
You can actually access Party Finder, find other people that may want to jump into Dark Citadel and group up with them.
And, of course, we have the additional communication tools with all the different pings that you can end up using and markers that you can end up using
to help kind of guide that whole entire group there.
So lots of cool stuff coming with Dark Citadel.
Really cool endgame content that's coming to Vessel of Hatred.
And we can't wait to see people jump into it.
Can't wait to jump into it myself.
But, of course, we have one last topic that we do want to talk about with Vessel of Hatred.
And that is our Mercenaries feature.
That is something that we did announce during Gamescom.
But we do want to go into a little bit of a deeper dive today on that specifically.
So, Brent, Dan, do you guys want to take us through Mercenaries?
Yeah.
Just to kick it off, you know, Mercenaries is one of those legacy features that you've seen in multiple Diablo games.
And when we started talking about this very early on, we're like,
what is the approach that we can take that really complements everything else that we're doing in Diablo 4 that is different?
Obviously, we've been touching things like itemization and we've been doing a bunch of reworks on class builds.
So, we knew a couple things here.
First, we wanted to make sure that the system was built in a way that could complement your build type, right?
So, every build type has a little bit of a soft spot.
And Mercenaries is a really good way of you can level them up in a way that can actually fill in that soft spot.
And the other thing that we really wanted to make sure of is that they were always useful, right?
And so, as you play along the game, you're interacting with them in way different ways than you would just by leveling up and using them basically as a power item, right?
And so, the way that we folded this in is far more robust than we've seen in other systems in the past.
And, yeah, I can't wait for Dan to show it off.
Awesome, yeah. Let's dive into it.
So, I think we can go to the first slide. Awesome.
So, we announced these characters at Gamescom.
And these are the four Mercenaries that you're going to meet as you play Vessel of Hatred.
Early on in the campaign, you're going to meet Rahir, the guy in the middle.
And you're going to lend him a hand in kind of tracking down these other characters, doing their questlines and unlocking them.
And they're like really involved questlines. They're pretty awesome.
They have cutscenes. They have, you know, a lot of narrative and backstory where you kind of get to know more about these characters.
And they have a lot of personality, so they're pretty interesting.
And we really want to make them feel like characters that live in the world.
They don't just sit in the hideout the whole time when you're running around and you might see an event where they're actually participating in the event.
So, you may even run into some of these characters before you unlock them.
Cool. So, today I'm going to cover a little bit more detail than what we announced at Gamescom.
I'm going to talk about play style and perk for each Mercenary.
I'm going to talk about reinforcements, which is a new way to interact with Mercenaries.
And then we're going to talk about bartering and progression at the end.
Alright. So, I'm going to talk about the play styles for each Mercenary.
And to start, I wanted to show an example of a skill tree.
So, every skill tree for a Mercenary at the very top, the starting node is their perk.
And this is a passive bonus you get whenever a Mercenary is hired into your party.
And they're pretty awesome. They're really powerful.
Hopefully, when you hire a Merc, you feel like they're changing the way you play.
And then every skill tree has six skills and 12 upgrades.
So, let's dive into some examples.
So, for Rahir, he's really like the tank if you need someone to help protect you.
And his skill tree is kind of split up into a tower shield, which is about getting in the thick of battle,
tanking things for you, taunting.
And he also has a round shield, which is sort of themed around being a holy protector.
So, the top node that you start with for Rahir, and this is when you hire him to your party, is Valiant.
And what this does is basically, if you take a lot of damage in one hit,
he's going to fly in, negate that damage, block it for you, and he's going to knock down enemies.
He's also going to grant you Unstoppable.
So, he can really save your life.
So, here's an example where this beast is going to hit me, and these guys hit pretty hard.
So, here comes, boom.
So, we're here kind of leapt in, he negated that damage, and he knocked them down.
So, that's awesome.
I imagine hardcore players will gravitate towards this unless they are risk takers.
So, definitely a very powerful perk.
Cool.
Let's talk about some upgrades.
I think we skipped ahead a slide if we want to go back one.
There we go.
Cool.
So, here's some upgrade examples on Rahir's skill tree.
The first one, Draw Fire.
We're going to show a video in a second.
Whenever I use a healing potion, Rahir's going to taunt enemies near him.
So, if you're in danger, you need health, it's going to help save you.
Iron Wolf's Virtue.
When Rahir's Valiance is triggered, he heals you, and his cooldown is reduced.
So, you can just get it to happen more often.
And he has a shield throw, which some D3 Crusader players might love, where he chucks his shield.
It bounces off some targets, and this kind of marks them.
So, you can sort of play whack-a-mole, and if you hit those targets, you'll get healed back.
So, it's another way to keep yourself alive.
All right.
Cool.
Let's check out an example for Draw Fire.
So, you're going to see I use my potion.
The UI would help you show it.
But, yeah.
I use the potion right there.
Rahir taunted everybody.
Sweet.
I did not die, and I'm happy.
All right.
Let's go to the next one.
So, Varyana.
We call her the Berserker Crone.
She is a reformed cannibal.
She's got a pretty interesting backstory.
I love her personality.
She's kind of zany and crazy.
She's also the cook for the mercenaries, and I don't know if I would eat her food.
I don't really trust her.
But her skill tree is kind of split up into two themes.
Dual-wield axes, which is all about visceral cleaves and bleeds.
And large mace, which is heavy slams.
So, you may be familiar with the massacre bonus from D3.
Her perk is very similar.
Where, basically, you get this bonus.
We could jump to the video.
And as you kill monsters, you're going to see when I get ten kills, the massacre bonus kicks in.
It's going to show up above her portrait on the left side of the screen.
So, it should say times ten.
Cool.
I now have a massacre bonus started.
As I build this up and I get it to higher thresholds, I'm going to get more and more movement speed.
So, you're kind of encouraged to play more aggressive.
Keep this going before it runs out of time.
And it sort of snowballs into this fun gameplay where you're going really fast.
So, you can embrace your inner Sanic and go real fast with Variana as your hired merc.
All right.
I got some upgrades for Variana.
So, Dismembering is...
Oh, yeah.
Sorry.
So, this one is going to guarantee an overpower.
She's going to knock people down.
And you get a guaranteed overpower.
So, if you're playing Barb, it's going to be really useful.
Reprisal is when you get CC'd, Variana is going to leap on the enemy that inflicted it and knock them down.
So, this can also save your life.
And no escape is Variana does whirlwind.
This makes it really big.
And as she's spinning around, she's kind of grouping enemies up for you.
So, that can be a fun one.
I think we showed both.
So, yeah.
Dismembering here.
So, she's going to set us up.
We get a guaranteed overpower.
You do a bunch of damage.
Sweet.
That feeds into, you know, a lot of builds.
And then we have Reprisal here.
So, I got chained by that monster.
She leapt on them, knocked them down.
Basically, canceling that for me.
All right.
Cool.
Subo the Bounty Hunter.
He's themed on longbows, which is precision shooting and traps.
The other side of his tree is crossbows, heavy bolts, and explosives.
And his perk is kind of broken up into two parts.
So, he has a passive component, which is he reveals enemies and materials on the mini-map.
And his active component is that he, we call him the Bounty Hunter, because he's going to call out targets during combat.
And if you kill that target, you get a bunch of resource back.
And also, the more you do that, the more often he's going to be casting Seeker.
So, you're kind of trying to keep this up, where you want to make sure you're killing his targets and spending your resource before you do so.
And this lets you just cast more abilities, which always feels great.
All right.
Let's check out an example.
So, I'm in town.
I'm going to walk out here with Subo.
And you can look at the mini-map, top right.
And it's starting to populate with herbs and ore veins.
And you'll see all the monsters on the mini-map as well.
So, that's kind of his scouting component.
And, sorry, we're going to have to loop this one, because I talk too slowly.
But he also is marking a target.
And you saw when I killed them, I got a bunch of resource.
Yeah, I know a lot of people with Subo, especially, because the fact that he highlights, like, ore veins and things like that are pretty huge.
For people, especially with all the changes that we're adding to, like, how materials can also be used to maybe craft, like, legendaries and stuff.
So, Subo is kind of, like, my personal favorite.
It definitely embraces, I think, what Brent was talking about, too, where mercenaries are really about utility.
And they kind of add choices that maybe you wouldn't necessarily pick on your character.
Or they help you just kind of, like, fill gaps in your build.
Or maybe encourage you to do, you know, have more diversity in your build.
Maybe they expose new options for you.
So, it's pretty interesting.
All right, cool.
We're going to show off some Subo upgrades.
So, first, we have Share a Drink, which is whenever he throws his Molotov, there's a chance for him to drop a healing potion for you.
Mastermind, Subo's Wire Trap and Trip Minds gain 60% size.
And then you and Subo both have increased crowd control duration.
Thrill Seeker is going to reduce cooldowns for every monster hit.
So, here's an example of Share a Drink.
He threw a Molotov.
He dropped a potion for me.
And that can just help you more consistently get potions, which could definitely be useful for a lot of players.
All right.
Oldkin.
This is definitely a fan favorite.
We call him the Forsaken Child.
His tree is sort of split up into two magic types.
Fire magic, which is all about burning enemies and making them suffer.
And shadow magic, which is haunting souls that kind of like apply dots and spread to enemies.
His perk is dependent on what your skill tree choices are.
So, if you're on the fire side of the tree or the shadow, you will get different buffs and debuffs.
So, every once in a while, he's going to turn into a demon of one of those forms.
If he's on the shadow side, you and all the enemies around him become vulnerable.
If he's on the fire side, he's going to make it so all your direct damage applies burn to enemies.
But it's also draining your resource.
So, he's really themed around this kiss curse mechanic.
And whenever this happens, it can be a huge benefit.
But also, there's some downsides to it, potentially.
All right.
Cool.
So, he's casting some fire skills.
We're going to see Oldkin on the left.
He's turning into a fire demon.
This gives him a whole new skill set.
He's got immolation.
He's burning nearby enemies.
And he's helping kill everything.
And then you can see when I'm doing direct damage, it's applying burn.
But also, my resource is draining.
This is if I'm on the shadow side.
He turned into a shadow demon at the top.
He's going to do a cool ability where he pulls everyone into a line, lines them up for you.
That always feels really good.
And yeah.
In that one, he's making everyone vulnerable.
Sweet.
Let's talk about some upgrades for Oldkin.
So, I think this will be a lot of people's favorites.
Ember's Gift.
Whenever he casts Firestorm, if you stand in it, you're getting 33% of your primary resource per second.
And we're going to show a video of that in a sec.
Terrify.
He does Haunt.
Yeah, thank you.
He's got a 30% chance to apply invulnerable to enemies.
So, another way to get keywords applied to things.
And Burning Chaos.
That's his ult.
Whenever you cast your ult, it resets his.
Wave of Flame is really cool.
It's this giant fire wave that destroys enemy projectiles.
You can kind of run with it and fight inside of it.
And I've seen a lot of people get use out of that.
Cool.
Okay.
Let's check out Ember's Gift.
So, he's going to cast Firestorm.
And look at my resource.
It's just flying up really fast while I'm standing in this area.
So, it's a good way to kind of have this happen.
And then you just get to spam a bunch of abilities.
And Murder Monsters.
So, yeah.
Here's a quick example of, you know.
We do have a lot of keywords and ways for mercenaries to utilize them and spread them to enemies.
So, that can help with a lot of builds, too.
Yeah.
It's nice having an option to, like, add vulnerable to more enemies.
Especially, like, doing AOE or anything like that.
So, yeah.
Really cool to see.
I know, of course, we have.
There's other mechanics with mercenaries that we did want to talk about.
So, Dan, do you want to jump into how reinforcements actually works?
Yeah.
Let's talk about reinforcements.
So, I guess before I explain reinforcements, there are two methods of using mercenaries.
One is hiring them.
And that's for solo players.
So, if you're playing solo, you're not in a party, you can hire a mercenary.
Everyone, at all times, can also have a reinforcement.
So, if you're in a party, everyone has a reinforcement.
If you're solo, you get both.
And if you're playing solo, they have to be two different characters.
So, your hired mercenary has to be different from your reinforcement.
All right.
What the heck are reinforcements?
So, reinforcements are a new way to interact with mercs where you can kind of call a mercenary into battle,
have them perform a skill at an opportune moment.
And you get to sort of control when that happens.
And this reminds me a lot of, like, old school fighting games where you can kind of cast an ability
and a character will fly in off screen.
He'll do something really cool.
Hopefully, that helps you a lot.
And that's, you know, I think very much inspired by that.
Yeah.
It's like assist.
They jump in, they do something, and then they, like, pop back out.
So, it's really cool.
So, you're going to choose an opportunity, which is when does it happen?
You could link this to any of your action bar slots.
So, you could say, hey, when I press one and I teleport, the mercenary does this skill.
And then you choose a skill that you have unlocked for that mercenary.
All right.
Let's check out some examples.
So, this one's quick.
I'm going to cast teleport.
And you'll see Rahir appear.
And then he sort of flies in battle.
He does this triple slam.
He groups everyone up.
Grouping enemies up is always good.
Thank you, Rahir.
I drop a meteor on their head.
In this one, we cast bone prison.
And Ultkin shows up and casts firestorm for me.
There's going to be a lot of combinations here, I think, with, you know, all the different player abilities and all the different reinforcement skills.
So, I think it'll be really interesting to see how players utilize the system.
You can use it more defensively or more offensively.
And hopefully you agree, a lot of the skills give you added utility.
So, I think there's a lot of opportunities here to mix and match, which would be cool.
Another thing I'm excited about that is that the system is built to grow.
And so, our ability to add more conditions in which you bring them in and continue to grow potentially the powers that we can see, too.
It's a very robust system that can go a pretty long way.
So, it's great.
Yeah.
Cool.
Awesome.
And I think, finally, we want to talk about some bartering.
Yeah.
We're going to talk about rapport, which is the progression.
And then bartering.
But they're all tied together.
It's all one unit.
We're good.
It's all tied.
Yeah.
So, rapport is the progression for mercenaries.
And we could go ahead and jump to the first slide.
So, this is what the rapport looks like.
You may be familiar with this type of UI.
In this example, we're rank five.
The first four skill ranks are how you get your skill points for the skill tree.
We want you to unlock all the cool, fun abilities for mercs pretty quickly and up front.
After that point, it's all about upgrades for bartering.
And bartering, as we're going to show it off in a second,
but progressing your mercs improves the bartering system,
which is kind of a way to trade with mercenaries at the hideout and get really useful items.
So, the very last rank, we hovered over it quickly there.
You can actually repeat the very last rank for mercenaries and continue to earn the currency.
So, if you say, hey, I really like Ultkin.
I don't want to level anyone else up.
You could just keep playing this character and you'll keep getting resources.
Hopefully, we're encouraging you, though, with these upgrades to kind of rank up all your mercs
and keep making bartering better.
All right, let's talk about bartering.
So, at the hideout, you can talk to Fiera and she will pull up a UI where you can trade for items.
A lot of them are legendaries.
And as you upgrade your mercs, you're going to basically increase this list so you can find more interesting things.
Hopefully, you can find some really cool legendary items that you're excited about.
As you upgrade your mercs, you're going to get more chances for legendaries.
And each mercenary has an aspect category associated with them.
So, Ultkin, for example, gives you resource aspect caches.
So, if you level up Ultkin, that has a chance.
Instead of getting a resource legendary, you're going to get a resource legendary aspect cache.
And in this case, we open one of those caches.
Sweet, I got a bunch of items.
It's not exactly target farming, but it's a way to increase your chances of things you may be looking for.
There's going to be a lot of other really useful items in here like crafting materials, boss summoning parts,
some masterworking recipes, things like that.
And that's about it.
So, you can restock the supply on this.
And the currency you re-roll this inventory with is the same currency that you're spending to buy items.
So, you kind of have to pick and choose like, do I want to re-roll or do I want to wait?
And hopefully you see things that you're interested in and you buy them.
And then every day when you log in, you get one free re-roll.
Just trying to be nice to the players.
Hopefully you get what you want without having to waste all your pale marks.
And I think that's all we have for mercenaries today.
So, thank you for...
That's awesome.
Yeah, I love hearing about the bartering system because it's just another avenue for like,
hey, if I need masterworking materials or if I need boss summoning materials,
I can literally go and check and see if I can barter for it now
as another opportunity for getting those specific things, which is really, really cool to see.
So, Dan, thank you very much for walking us through the mercenaries coming to Vessel of Hatred.
And so, everything that this group actually talked about here, this is all exclusive to Vessel of Hatred.
So, with the expansion and anyone who actually ends up purchasing the expansion,
they'll be able to access all the different features that we talked about from Spiritborn
to Curious Under City to Dark Citadel and, of course, the mercenaries.
So, lots of stuff in the expansion specifically for this that we're all excited for everyone to jump into.
October 7th, 4 p.m. Pacific in California, globally, wherever your time zone is.
That it's tied to that.
That is when it will end up hitting.
So, we have a cool map.
But I know we talked about a lot today.
We do want to, of course, do our normal Q&A that we always do at the end.
But before we actually end up doing that, I know, Brent, you wanted to talk a little bit about the journey here.
Yeah, honestly, you know, we talk at the team level a lot about our communication with the community at this point.
And I've said it a few times where it's like it feels so good to be in a dialogue now.
And everybody at home, you've heard us say, we're listening, we're listening.
I actually feel like we're well beyond that point at this moment.
Like, we really feel like the community is now one of our team members.
And we're developing together at this point.
And we're starting to all pull in the same direction.
And we've learned so much, right?
We've come out with Season 1.
We took some lumps there, right?
We knew we had a lot of work to do.
And all the dialogue that we've had has led up to things like the success of Season 4 and Season 5.
And so the fact that the community is really a part of our team now, it shows us a great pathway.
We still have a lot of work to do.
You know, there's things we want to get to.
Yeah.
Armory.
We just end development.
Yeah.
So we talked about that a little bit at Gamescom.
But these are the types of things that are really fine-tuning the way we can get there.
And honestly, we couldn't get there without all of you at home.
Thank you for staying with us on this journey.
Can't wait to get to the Q&A.
Yeah.
And again, just to reiterate what Brent was saying, I think the community is speaking about how they really wanted us to have a PTR,
having those PTR moments, having players in earlier, being able to provide that feedback.
Huge shout-out to you guys for being able to help us out with this journey that we've been on.
We've made some massive strides since the first season, and it's only getting better from here, which is really cool.
So awesome.
Well, I think we're going to jump into the Q&A.
We're actually going to bring some people in from before, swap people out, do the musical chair thing again, musical chairs thing again.
And we'll see you here in a minute for the Q&A.
If you guys have questions, please start teeing them up in chat, and we'll try to get to as many questions as possible.
So we'll see you in a minute.
Thank you.
We'll be right back.
So,
this is from,
Razzle,
this is actually from,
this is from,
this is from a lot of people.
This is from a lot of people.
Speaking of D2,
I'm wearing my D2 jacket.
Will we get the D4 campfire screen back?
So, we were talking about it during the interstitial just a little bit. Yeah, I think if we could feel a vibe through a monitor, like that was the moment that came through. You know, we hear it loud and clear. One of the things that we are doing is trying to set ourselves up for success, for adding more.
Classes to the mix. And so, the campfire is one of those things where we're taking a look at it and trying to figure out how that would work. And so we updated it where we are kind of like really in and you don't get that initial setup. So that is something that like immediately when the feedback started coming out, I think it was a little bit earlier.
We had to make sure we had a lot of feedback that we needed to do, but we needed to do more. And so we updated it where we are kind of like really in and you don't get that initial setup. So that is something that like immediately when the feedback started coming through, the team started to mobilize and talk about what we can do. Turning it around in time fast enough for like Vessel of Hatred was we had other things like balance and polish that we really wanted to pay attention to.
Make sure some of the UI elements for some of the new features were in a good spot. So we hear you. I love the fact that the nostalgia means so much. And so the team is actively talking about it and we'll be able to get back to you in the future.
Awesome. Yeah, that was by far a very, very popular topic after PTR. They're like, where's the campfire?
Every moment we learn.
I can see like the flames kind of like in the screen, but where is like the full on campfire?
Yeah.
We have a question from Ram Zero, which is, will there be more renown and statues of Lilith in this expansion? How does that specifically work?
Yeah, we're not going to be doing statues of Lilith specifically. We're going to be having a new statue type.
The Tenant of Akurat.
Tenant of Akurat, which is, it's not going to give you any points, but it is working towards renown. And so there's still a lot of discoverability in the zone, but we're shifting things to work more for renown.
Yeah. And statues of Lilith, of course, are still in the base.
They still exist.
Thank you for clarifying.
The stats, we're just not giving stats for the Tenant of Akurat because we saw how frustrated players were with like having to do this sort of activity to get more powerful.
Correct.
So it's a lot more leaning into the collectible aspect.
Yeah.
We didn't want these to feel like a chore that you needed to do in order to progress your player power. It's all about the discoverability, right?
In the new zone.
Yeah.
And I will say that the other thing with renown specifically, like we made changes. It's something we talked about during the PTR, but we kind of optimized it a little bit better.
Because there was like paragon points at the last tier of renown and that's actually been like swapped back around now. So it's more of like the oval upgrades are at the last tier.
Yeah. Yeah. It's easier to get that potent power from paragon. We also just sort of reduced how much renown you need for a lot of these things.
So if you missed out on renown when the game came out, it's a lot easier to get that power.
Yeah. It's good. Good way for people, like especially friends who maybe are jumping into Diablo 4 just to like kind of catch up specifically from that end.
One thing, this just dawned on me that I did want to also mention is that, you know, back in Season 3, we introduced the gauntlet.
And that has, you know, the leaderboard mechanics and stuff like that. One thing I do want to actually do a quick call out on is like when Season 6 starts and when Vessel of Hatred actually does ship.
We do plan on actually sunsetting the gauntlet and the leaderboard functionality there. Does that mean leaderboards are going away forever? No, that doesn't mean leaderboards are going away forever.
We're actually looking at new ways of potentially finding a home for it.
Yeah. I'd rather say like leaderboards are vaulted as we do a big reassessment on how that applies to the new progression actually we're looking at releasing with Season 6.
So I think that there's a lot of opportunity there. But again, we've made so much change.
It's a time to take a deep breath and then take a look at the things that we really want to invest into.
Yeah. Awesome. Almost forgot about that. I wanted to mention that.
There's a question from Avvience which is saying like, hey, how does Group Finder work?
This was actually available during PTR and I know not everyone got to experience PTR but kind of like Party Finder itself.
Of course, you can use it across multitudes of activities from Dark Citadel, beyond Dark Citadel, which is being introduced in Vessel of Hatred.
But it is a feature that you can also use or that allows you to actually use filters and different ways of searching for specific groups and people.
So we do recommend jumping in, checking out the Party Finder. It's actually super, super awesome.
And I know there's going to be improvements that will continuously be made to it.
Yeah. Another system that we're trying to develop in a way that can grow with the player.
And so we got it out in PTR to try to get an initial round of feedback on the types of filters that we could potentially see.
You know, as we add the activities to the game, we want to make sure that those are plugging into it as well.
We do think that this game is a ton of fun if you're playing together. And so we've designed it to do exactly that.
We have a question regarding Opals and Tributes that we kind of showed off.
Tributes, of course, being part of Cure Ass Under City, Opals being part of the new season.
This question was from PVE Sweat.
Great.
I think the initial reaction is seeing some of these new consumables.
So, Tim, I think this would be a quick question for you.
Like seeing these new consumables, are they actually stackable in inventory?
Yeah, yeah, yeah. You can stack them in inventory.
In fact, if you want, you have the option, you can go just farm the Realm Walker over and over again,
get a whole bunch of the Opals, and then just, okay, I'm going to play now for hours and hours with the buff active,
if that's something you want to do. And Tributes as well are stackable.
Awesome.
I did like the fact, too, I don't know, I can't recall if we mentioned it, but you get two Tributes with every drop.
Yes.
And so you don't...
Sorry, two Opals.
Two Opals, sorry.
Yeah.
So you can like use one now and save one for later, and so you can really determine like,
you can actually stack these up for a longer play session later on if you wanted to play in the weekend and actually really dig in.
There is a question regarding Mercenaries. It's actually a question I've seen. Maybe it's a two-parter, but a lot of people are asking specifically like,
hey, do Mercenaries... How does the progression of Mercenaries kind of carry over? Is it something that's across like the whole entire account? Or is it like from season to season? How does that specifically work?
Yeah. So they're partition-wide. So if you're playing in the season and you unlock the Mercs and you progress a bunch of them and then you roll an Alt, that progression is still there.
But we do reset every season because it's a part of the power journey and we want to make sure you're doing that. But as you're playing, there's a lot of benefits to investing into them, especially if you're going to roll a second class.
There is a question. I'm not sure if others will be able to get this one, but this might be tied to some of the rune word stuff that we showed, but this is God King Moonen says,
how do those spirit wolves damage scaling work? I think they're talking specifically about the rune words that we were showing and everything like that.
Yeah, I can talk a bit about that. I believe the spirit wolves are not currently scaling with things like if you have summoning damage for a Necromancer.
A lot of that damage scaling talks directly to your skeleton summons at the moment. So I don't believe they'll necessarily scale with those sources.
I'd have to check on precisely which ones it does. But that's definitely something that we're aware of and really want to make sure that we can deliver on that fantasy.
And we'll be looking at making updates to minions and summons as a general matter going forward to really make sure that they're scaling with the right things that players expect to really make those builds feel natural and synergistic as you would expect.
So that's definitely an area of focus for us moving forward.
Yeah, we definitely have talked a lot about this online. It'd be cool if you could be a summoner barb called Ancients and having them deal bulkier damage.
So that's something we definitely talk a lot about.
Yeah, we don't have any particular thing to announce or the exact initiative at this moment, but it's definitely on our radar and it's something we are actively working on and talking about all the time.
Awesome. I know that I am the berm asked this is back to Tim actually because I think you had mentioned like farming realm walkers and they're going like, okay, so is it a world event?
How often does it spawn? Like what like do we have like specifics on that? We can help clarify on that specific question.
It is a world event. Yeah, and it is really focused around just that boss. It's not a world boss exactly. It is a world event.
Like was explained by Don earlier in the cast, you have to kind of follow him for a while before you're allowed to kill him.
But it is something that you do with other people in the area. There's likely to be a bunch of other people helping you take down this boss.
And then the realm walker itself does pop up in another location in Sanctuary pretty much right away. There's a slight break, but at any given time we want the experience to be I log in, I'm ready to go play.
I see like, I don't have any opals. Can I go get some? We want the answer to pretty much always be yes. Like there's always a realm walker up somewhere that you can go kill.
So I guess you can get slightly unlucky like he just died, but you're not waiting more than a few minutes before another one's going to pop up and you can go kill that one. So if you want to chain farm them, you can.
Yeah, just run back to town vendor some stuff by the time you come back. It will probably be a like, you know, an ideal time to actually farm it.
So it's actually really good to hear that. That's just always available for players pretty or nearly always available for players.
Question from Plucky Villain for season six on live like from a tuning and balance perspective is pit 100 still intended to be like that unobtainable goal or is there are we expecting some of like the most skilled players and dedicated players to kind of clear it?
Yeah, I'd say we will be surprised but not surprised I guess to see people get to pit tier 100 just with the amount of things that we're adding into the game. Charles, you know, in our previous segment talked about how much volatility has been introduced in the expansion. We actually think that's really fun. Like there's a ton of new things to explore. A ton of new things to break. And we think that probably most people won't get to 100 but you might get a surprise if you go to 100 and go past it.
Yeah, we might have done something there. Yeah, we talked quite a bit about where the deep end of the pool is, right?
It's around 80. Around 80. Yeah, but yeah, I'm really looking forward to seeing which kind of streamers out there actually push way past that so we can take a look.
Definitely. Your Sparrow asks, if we complete the campaign in an eternal realm, will we be able to skip it when we create a seasonal character?
Yes, as soon as you complete the campaign for the first time you'll be able to skip it. Very similar to what we did in the base game.
Yeah, and I think there's actually like additional nuances that we've added with Vessel of Hatred. Like for instance, if you are brand new to Diablo, of course we recommend you start from the base game and experience the campaign and that journey.
But even if you are coming into Diablo 4 with Vessel of Hatred and you just want to start with Vessel of Hatred, you really just need to complete that prologue of the base game and then you will then get that option I believe to skip the base campaign and you can actually jump into the expansion campaign.
You actually don't even have to complete the prologue.
Oh, there we go.
You even took out that point.
You're a liar, Adam. You're a liar.
And we've taken great care of you too. So like if you're new and you skip forward, when you go to go into Vessel of Hatred, we actually do recaps. So we'll catch up on the story even if you decide to do it. So if your friends are all way ahead of you and you want to skip so that you can catch up, you're good.
Yeah. We got one of those like in the last episode of whatever.
Yeah. It's really good.
Yeah. It's actually really cool to watch. So just in case if you're new to everything.
There's another detail too, which is like once you play through the Vessel of Hatred story section, we want way more players to get into the end game.
We notice that there's a lot of folks out there that once they get their big story beats done, it's not really clear on where to go from there.
And so we created a custom quest that can actually bridge you out into the end game.
And so if you can continue following your golden baubles, that would be super good.
Cool. Awesome.
We're seeing a sign in the peanut gallery.
I'm looking at it.
Oh, I was stuck.
I was like, what is pretty? No one can see it obviously.
They think we're psycho because we're like looking back on what's going on.
The coolest view is behind this camera.
Production's like holding up the sign and stuff.
Everybody that makes us look good is back there. So thank you guys.
Yes. Thank you very much.
We're going to take, I guess, like one more specific question here.
Let me see.
This is actually a question regarding people that are running specifically in Dark Citadel.
Like if someone leaves during Dark Citadel, like what happens to the group specifically?
Can they all just leave? They're not like locked in there.
Like, oh gosh, I'm stuck in that type of situation.
Or if I can conquer it with like maybe if it's four people and we drop to three, like you can adapt and kind of work your way through it.
You can. Like we said, the game, the Citadel is down balance for four.
But if that was to drop, as long as you got two strong players still in the mix, you should be good to go.
So yes, it makes it more difficult.
I'd have a firm conversation with the person who decided to drop in the middle of a fight.
But yeah, you're still going to be able to progress through it.
Awesome. Cool.
Well, I know we've been going for a while here and we wanted to grab as many questions as possible so we don't keep people too long.
Because the biggest thing as well is like after at the end of the stream, we are releasing the patch notes.
And I know a lot of people want to dive into the patch notes.
But I guess before we kind of drop off, like Brent, I know you wanted to give a quick message out as well.
Yeah, you know, we saw this really cool piece of art that was made by one of our art directors on the team.
And it just really reminded us that there are hundreds of people working on this game all of the time.
And these live streams are for our community, but it's also for all the folks who have been working tirelessly over the last dozens of months on trying to make this a reality.
And so we just want to say thank you to everybody that's putting the hard work in.
And we're still putting the hard work in today.
Like we're working all the way up through this.
And so we love the team.
We love you guys.
Keep up the good work.
And yeah, we'll see you on the other side of October 8th.
October 8th.
Yeah.
Huge shout out to Team 3, Team Diablo.
You guys kick ass.
Yeah.
Best team.
We're super proud of everyone with a vessel of hatred and everything.
And we're super excited for October 8th.
There's a lot of stuff coming up.
We have patch notes immediately after this stream.
I want to give a huge shout out to everyone here and of course who was on the live stream today.
It's always fun doing these live streams.
It's a big scramble.
This is the most amount of people we've ever had on a live stream.
So huge shout out to our production team and of course our community team like with Mr. Filthy Rich back there who organizes all these great...
That's his handle guys.
Who handles, who handles, handles, haha.
All these specific streams every single time.
This is our 20th stream.
It's crazy to see how everything has grown.
Big reminders on Twitch drops.
We have all the information on Diablo4.com.
Twitch drops will actually start on October 8th.
And if you're in the US, you can grab trolleys and grab more in-game stuff as I eat trolleys all day.
And then another big thing that I do want to give a quick call out.
In the coming days you guys are actually going to hear about another cool partnership we're doing with Discord which will offer up another opportunity for some cool in-game stuff.
And we'll be talking about that here in the coming days.
But thank you guys again for tuning in to our pre-launch stream.
Lots of stuff to check out in the patch notes immediately after the stream.
And again, a huge thanks to everyone here.
We will see you guys October 8th in Nahantu.
We're excited and we can't wait to jump into Vessel of Hatred.
We'll see you guys.